let's go all righty
all right going live
you guys have moderators
all right reject nation if you're here
you know what to do let us know if we're
live if you can hear us
we had time today to calibrate the
microphones so everything should be
groovy and before we even kick this off
just because you know we're here we all
know why we're here what we're here to
discuss and we want to know if you guys
have seen the movie once twice what did
you think now it's out so if you'll turn
your attention to the chat a poll is
about to pop up and uh and you'll be
able to participate in that but greg
coy
how you guys doing today thank you for
joining me yeah thanks john thanks john
yeah
remember you guys
what do you got there that's what i'm
doing i got the uh the son of loki
awesome
so right now what john's doing is he's
going to the chat the poll he's going to
put out a poll for you guys asking what
did you guys think of eternals
and you got three options to vote on
and uh we just want to know we just want
to give you an idea you guys remember
you drive the way this spoiler talk goes
the reason why we like doing spoiler
talks live is because whenever we shoot
a like you know pre-recorded live no
proof or live stream we recorded live
stream yeah we just fooled the audience
whenever we recorded pre-recorded
spoiler talk um i'm always left with the
feeling when i'm editing of damn it i
forgot that didn't talk about this
didn't talk about this didn't talk about
this so
if anything's left off the table
you're to blame you blame the audience
blame the audience
yeah you blame the audience that's how
you engage
make sure they're saying build a
community you blame the community
it must be the kids are to blame
all righty all righty let's see let's
see how this poll goes i'm expecting
most people to say love it right now
we've got okay all right all right all
right most people are loving it so
67 votes we'll check it again in a
second yeah yeah we'll keep it we'll
keep it pinned up there and i know i
usually lead these streams but
i want to say right here right now
john's going to be leading everything
welcome well i'm going to try my best to
be quiet welcome to i'm going to try my
best to not interrupt him yes i'm going
to try my best to let him talk yeah you
know try my best to be in the background
really respectful
always respectful of my train of thought
let's do it okay so you got the son of
searcher i got the sort of searcher yes
sir son of sorcerers pastry style with
coffee cacao chocolate sandwich cookies
and marshmallows oh good god there's so
much in this it's not even funny so the
stream is gonna go way off the rails
seeing a lot of responses in the chat
that are very uh across the board though
i mean i saw somebody put eleven out of
ten seven a half out of ten five out of
ten eight and a half out of ten a lot of
varying opinions on this i liked it
followed by i hate it back to back that
is a nice summary of the internet that
is just the internet at large movie or
no
what is the uh you gotta make sure
you're really talking to the mic there
koi don't be a dick yeah don't be an
anus don't be here
all right but um what is the poll at
right now the poll is at oh it's
fluctuated too it's holding on most
people liked it or loved it 44
leading the loved it category only two
percent of our of our viewers today have
hated it though all right out of 370
votes yeah that's more votes than rotten
tomatoes
yeah i do want to acknowledge at the top
of this i was exactly wrong uh the
numbers i thought it was going to be are
exactly inverse and i'm honored by that
i'm happy to own that because you guys
you the people the audience you've given
me more hope in mankind you've proven to
me that there is a patience and an
actual uh uh attention span in the
people so thank you for proving me wrong
i've never been happier to be wrong i
loved this movie and i'm really happy to
see that the people are enjoying it as
well i thought this was just me a
critical darling but it's actually like
doing really well it's got 161.7 box
office the second biggest box office
worldwide i think to fast and furious is
number one did 71 million domestic
during a pandemic era it's a huge box
office so the people i appreciate you is
it 71 million yeah i didn't know the
numbers i got you didn't sleep much yeah
i was just reading the stream
i
had so much and i remember it was out
pretty late last night but uh oh that's
good that's awesome
but now we'll just see the work because
it's got a b cinema score right now
which is it's not terrible it's the
lowest in the mcu so far which is a
testament to the mcu in my opinion yes
absolutely it's the lowest in the mc
yeah they never hit c
so
now we just gotta wait and see how it
performs over the next couple of weeks
because that's the real telling of word
of mouth because you can get like people
going around tomatoes and chiming in
giving their you know the the upping the
percentage there because i think it's
like 84 right now somewhere there yeah
which is pretty good and then you got b
cinema score but we'll see if the word
of mouth is actually indeed stronger as
the weeks progress
i'm also curious how the week one week
two drop-off is because it's you know
the first week is when all the people
that are passionate about seeing it it's
a longer movie there's only so many show
times you can squeeze in a schedule
because it's so long you can get like
three to screen um because movie
theaters are open to limited hours right
now especially around la uh but i'm
really curious about the word of mouth
if people are gonna be going back if
it's going to change the overall
perspective like obviously you can't
change the cinema score but we saw that
imdb got rev review bomb before it even
came out how that changes those things
are interesting to me because there is
this really strong uh aggressive offense
to it like i've not seen this much
aggression towards a marvel film since
captain marvel
uh yeah it was because if you go woke
you go broke i mean clearly that's why
it's on 161.7 million dollars which is
bro history everything's broke and
that's why the critics who love woke
culture gave it a lower score by half
than the audience who isn't woke
apparently i've i just gotta say this
whole thing about critics
being treated as if they're part of some
secret society they're not human beings
this brain has mine
together
most of these people were just fans who
then eventually
worked their way up and then they got
them they were able to become rotten
type like them are our friends most a
lot of them are many of them yeah
i've seen people in the chat say that
critics are biased and i'll let you know
a little secret viewers are biased yeah
every viewer everyone's a little bit
biased that's why we have varying
opinions everyone has tastes everybody
has what they like and dislike and what
works for them and critics have not
exempted that the only difference
between critics and the normal audience
is critics
likely have seen a lot more movies
and that's about it yeah
well we saw it a second time yeah and uh
the second time watching it it was like
the first time john and i watched it
together and we see some questions
coming in and we're going to get to them
john's going to be making sure we're
doing everything going on he's reading
he's got he's reading your live chat as
well yeah so
uh the second time we saw it you know
okay i did a quick out of the theater
thoughts with john everyone thought that
was a full review but then if you watch
them coy which is like an hour long
you'll see that there's one is a very
short one my favorite thing i've ever
done on the internet conversation is one
of my favorite things i've ever made
that's i'm happy to hear that i'm happy
to see you got a lot of love for it i
also rewatched it and i never re-watched
anything like it's like you were there
so like why would you be like i'm gonna
go relive my life for an hour we skipped
over everything i said and this guy's
still talking this great guy no but i'm
just saying like i think we did really
fine work there and i'll say on the
second time around there were specific
character moments that definitely worked
for me that were i thought were stronger
there are things that worked less for me
the second time around though
um i'm pretty
like
overall it's okay you guys probably
heard my opinion a gazillion times by
this point i did a very long talk with
koi obviously i'm not in the hated camp
for this movie it's one of those things
where i personally just didn't really
feel much when i watched it although
i'll say the second time around i
actually did get a little misty-eyed
when fastos has to say bye to his son
that's one of my two that was that that
part really got to me um when he's
motivated by that love but see that's my
bias though parental
actions of love really get to me that's
a bias but i'm not sitting there going
like i'm [ __ ] biased towards this you
know
that that is uh that's definitely a
quality and i actually think
you know and and i see or before we went
live that this character was getting a
lot of crap in the chat
i actually think my favorite characters
the second time around are specifically
sprite and kingo
because because of the fact that i think
they represent
what i personally might have wanted most
out of the eternals movie because if you
look at the lives they're leading
they're the representatives of eternity
and the ways one can go really well and
beneficial and the way one can really go
tragically wrong whereas like i love the
portrayal of sprite because the first
time around i was like she's really good
a bit whiny but really good and then the
second time around i'm like oh this
makes perfect sense why she would always
be in a bad mood five the most portrayed
seven thousand years stuck in this body
and then early in that scene her first
scene in the present day when she's like
flirting with a guy but then the second
she touches he uh he touches her hand
you know she starts to fade away because
she's really a little girl's like and
then she can't she's this person in a
little girl's body but she's an adult so
and it'd also be weird if she dated a
like a 12 year old boy or something you
know like she can't win she can't have
intimacy she can't experience the love
and yet she's like pretty much playing
roommate to cersei who's in this really
loving relationship and so she has she's
i could see that she's envious of that
and then not only that but then cersei
also gets icarus the guy who she's
really in love with so she's kind of in
this suffrage position and then king
goes on the opposite perspective where
he gets to like delight and celebrate
and be famous yeah take advantage of
being eternal you know and so i i
thought like their dichotomy and then
they had a couple of key scenes together
like in the forest when kingo is he's
doing the peter pan tinker bell
discussion and he's the one who's able
to pick up on that and she's in love
with icarus there was something about
their specific dynamics and the story
that i thought they were telling and i
thought sprite had the most
interesting development especially by
the end when cersei is able to grant her
like the pinocchio wish become human so
i i actually appreciate that more though
do you have a favorite too i i think
it'd be a fun way to go through the
start yeah yeah sure what are your top
two you know i really appreciate what
you just said and one of the biggest
things about the second viewing to me
was that that character thread with
sprite became super clear it's like one
of the clearest character threads in the
movie is like practically every scene
someone makes a crack at her about her
appearance her age her predicament and
that that really drove home that sort of
like family dysfunction
vibe but um yeah i still for me my two
favorites to watch and partly because i
don't want to steal your answer because
i i do agree like i i really came out
loving kingo and and uh sprite the
second time but it's still drug in
makari for me like i love them together
i think them as individual characters
even not having as much of the lion's
share of the screen time or whatever
like every time those two stepped on
screen whether together or apart i was
really compelled just by their presence
their performances i think makari's
action is some of the coolest and most
like i i like this movie a lot and upon
second viewing i still held a lot of my
opinions of all the marvel movies it's
not the one that gets me hooping and
hollering the most but those makari
scenes where she's like fighting icarus
and where she's like you know running
around the world trying to find the
point of the emergence like those are
are so dazzling and those were the
moments where i was like yeah get him um
for this movie and then yeah druid uh
just his presence and his pov like you
know i think all the characters could
have been to some degree expanded um but
i i really liked just yeah the kind of
philosophical edge he was coming from
his relationship to makari his way of
interacting with everybody else
uh yeah that would probably be mine too
with a close close second uh no let's
let's let's
do all ten if you want one well so i do
think it's interesting that the power
set and that's one of the things i want
to talk about as we evolve into this
conversation is their powers tie so
closely to their world view in such a
fascinating way they were able to have
us endear ourselves to these characters
so quickly by their power set being how
they perceive the world which is kind of
how humans are like our strengths are
how we perceive things so my two were
druid and athena because i feel like
druid he just wants to ease pain he's
trying to solve problems he sees the the
fallibility of man and he just wants to
help people and he does that in a way
that would be villainous and handled in
other hands in a lot of ways it is a
very terrifying concept but there's a
reason that cults happen there's a
reason that this this power this charm
this inherentness alters people but he
uses it in a way where he's actually
altruistic in his mind and it's a thing
where is freedom of choice a negative we
talk about that in most great literature
like what our freedom of choice causes
us harm and how it benefits mankind all
those things and i think it ties
beautifully into fast doses where he
just wants to further us but conflict is
what makes us stronger so in the
conversation of conflict making us
stronger like every time we have a
problem we have to solve it we invented
computers to solve this thing industrial
revolution solved this thing but those
also inherently cause wars and cause
death but you've got a character like
druid who on the micro scale is able to
solve that problem but if druid had had
his way we wouldn't have potentially
been the people we are today so it is
this beautiful micro to the 10 character
macro of why they couldn't step forward
so we got to see one of the characters
actually do the thing they all
individually wanted to do
while never seeing him as a villain even
our villain in quotes icarus all icarus
does is follow orders we're gonna talk
about that more later because it is a
fascinating commentary on villainy but
my second favorite character is thena
because in my opinion we've never seen
mental illness handled in a superhero
film with any sort of delicateness we've
seen lots of villains that are mentally
ill we've seen lots of characters that
have mental handicaps treated with scorn
and ostracized or made into lepers but
athena is stronger for it she's the only
one that actually sees the reality of
things the mind weary actually makes her
the one that evolves into what's
actually happening and i've never been
diagnosed with [ __ ] but you guys
complain all the time about how fast i
talk and i'm just so bored all the time
so i'm sure i've got something wrong
because the world feels very [ __ ]
slow to me so i've always identified
with these characters that are slightly
on some sort of radar that are
characters that are like slightly
unhinged and usually these characters
that are unhinged or treated as villains
or treated as lesser and this she was
treated as more and she was able to
bring an emotionality and a heart and a
soul through the power of jolie to make
me
feel like less of a weirdo so between
the irish lilt and the beautiful sounds
of my [ __ ] home country and angelina
jolie this is a movie that made me feel
more welcome in this world through these
gods
it was that was beautiful
so happy you feel that way
i'm really happy for you i know i mean i
like we're if we're talking about biases
and
i don't want to make things about like a
biased argument or i would never try to
sway someone from not from feeling
opposite i was out yesterday and a
couple people were asking me about
eternals and they just start spitballing
they're reviewing me and i'm just like
i'm happy is that the weirdest feeling
yeah when you're out and people are like
let me tell you what i think we weren't
let me challenge you to my opinion yeah
i'm just like i'm more than happy if you
love it that's great
uh
okay um
what's funny is
is that there are things about this that
i liked less this time around and some
became clear as to why and this kind of
ties into my problem with how i actually
don't like the way theme is handled in
this movie interesting now you might not
have been diagnosed with a lot
i've been diagnosed with a lot
and honestly that doesn't even matter to
me like what i'm what i'm saying with
that like because i think you're right
in the sense of what they wanted to do
with ena
my overall issue with the flashbacks
before i go right into athena and then
we do have to get to the questions so
sorry
my overall issue with the way and you
know what's funny is john's definitely
more in your camp but i think we're a
little bit eye to eye on this one yeah
are we i believe i believe that you and
i are pretty much on the same page about
athena
i felt like she's kind of the most
underwritten underdeveloped character in
here
and
really quick the reason a big part of
that is the way the flashbacks are
handled in the first hour because i was
actually timing it on a clock here so
the first hours when you're really
cutting back to the past watching what
led them to kind of
uh go their separate ways right
and
i can never feel anything in those
flashbacks because we were always
going to the flashbacks at the end of
the flashback do you get what i mean
yeah that's always the catalyst it's
it's always like always
called the thesis moment i'm like it's
hard for me to really care about drugs
dilemma here because i never watched him
struggle with this i'm just now learning
he's struggling with this and now here
we are and same thing with athena every
time we saw her she was just quiet or
doing fight scenes like she was fighting
and then
when we get to the moment where she's
experiencing mad weary
i was like i'm like you're doing a
really great job actually
like you really really showed up i can
feel you really built this character
but i i don't feel i'm like i don't
you're just like but i want to remember
who i am and it really hit me the second
time around of i have no idea who you
are though i have no clue who you really
are because this movie hasn't explored
it for me at least one one bit and then
i think you're right and that's kind of
the uh metaphorical realm they wanted to
go down that path of mental illness
i really feel like they didn't
ever explore it whenever they showed it
a lot of the time to me it was kind of
just like a supernatural takeover moment
just like like like when they first show
up in where they camped out in australia
gilgamesh and and her and then she
breaks out and she like spouts a line
and they kind of use her more for plot
clues of the former memories of the
eternals before their brains get wiped
right that's kind of what i felt she was
used for although i do like the moment a
lot
i will i can't deny this i love the
moment when uh her the performance
when she's with gilgamesh in the forest
and then she's struggling against it
because and there i got the i got the
character a lot she's you know she's the
warrior from olympia at least that's
what she believes right she's a warrior
from olympia this is the greatest
warrior
and there she is feeling like she can't
even intervene in the fight to go help
gilgamesh
like that was a good moment um but then
as as the movie progressed a lot of
times i kind of just felt like she was
just
like kind of just there but the most
underdeveloped one of them all and then
it really hit me in the scene when she
does have that speech with cersei on the
ship towards the end i kind of felt i
got the impression that they were like
we need to write something for athena to
do so to say
and then she has like jokes in there and
humor that felt very forced to me they
didn't feel natural to me that like that
to me was the most marvel forced humor
when they thrusted it onto finna's
character it just never
didn't click with me so her character
specifically i thought was no i don't
want to say angel angeline joe lee did a
bad job i really think the writing on
her was a very lackluster personally
it's john don't say quiet help me out
here man
because i've been trying to figure out
the words
because this was the thing because i i
was sitting there both times watching it
going angelina jolie she showed up for
this i really like her presence i i'm
happy that she's so invested in this
role clearly and it is a strange
phenomenon to me where she is the one of
the ensemble who doesn't quite feel
plugged in to the rest of the movie as
much as everybody else does and right
now as i'm sitting here i think part of
that is to me it feels like a lot of her
struggle
we don't really experience from her
point of view so much as she is the
object of everybody else's concern and
it's like how do we handle her how do we
you know
nurture her through this and not have to
reset her memories and stuff like that
and she's the object of a lot of those
conversations and she sells the
performance of the anguish of that but i
did get and this is just speculation but
i got the sense that
things might have been excised or paired
out from you know flashbacks about her
or something but if her
uh memories are so important to her and
if we leave the movie in a place where
irishm comes back and is like you know
your memories will be scanned for
judgment basically i thought they could
have used that as a motif and really
plugged it into the movie of we don't
know he's gonna
come back with that line but make
something out of the memories and do
some surreal kind of i don't know do one
of those trippy marvel sequences where
you can't quite tell what's reality and
you're flipping in and out through
different memories or something to make
that feel like a really plugged in lucid
part of the movie because for most of
the other characters i really felt like
i saw through everyone's point of view
at some point or another
but i didn't see through her point of
view yeah to defend my thena absolutely
uh the for me i felt like the using her
less made it more mysterious which
allowed for more of the unreliable
narrator aspect of wondering what she's
going through and leaning into emotion
instead of logic and we actually talked
about in our spoiler free review the
intellectual feeling versus the
emotional feeling and you were saying
how there was a lot of stuff you didn't
emotionally connect with that i happen
to have yeah and i think that's gonna be
one of the interesting things about
people assessing this film i i guarantee
a lot of people that love this were able
to connect off very little versus people
that wanted to love this that didn't
weren't able to connect because of the
size of the cast i guarantee there's
moments that for me registered as like
okay that's gonna last me 20 minutes
until we get back to blah blah blah
because i'm so like wrong and therefore
by the time it gets back to you you're
like i'm covering the character off and
that's a-okay because it's not a
weakness it's just an inherent art form
it's it's art is so subjective for a
reason so you can't possibly have all 10
of these characters have enough time so
some people i i do want to stress and
it's been a very interesting
conversation because you don't like this
movie it doesn't make you dumb or a bad
person there's been so much attacking
people about this movie it's it's not a
matter of that it's a matter of like
whether or not it resonated i don't
think any less of anyone that hated this
movie unless you hate it because of the
color people's skin their sexuality
their religious beliefs if you're a
bigot i hate you in general so it's just
going to tie into eternity i gotta can i
interrupt really quick
there are i don't think this is rotten
tomatoes who are a bunch of homophobes
and racist and sexist not at all
there are definitely and i have spoken
to a couple of people
there's a couple people i've tried
having like
a real discussion with
there are people who literally just
are that oh no that's what i'm saying
watch this movie and then when that [ __ ]
pops up
it's gonna it it makes them hate the
movie and it's not mutually exclusive is
what i'm saying i'm saying like because
of that you are not there and a lot of
people have been like hey i don't want
you to think i'm blah blah and have this
weird caveat i was like i'm not assuming
that of you yeah but at the same time
that is going to ostracize or put out a
large number of people and it and it's
so alarming to me that one of the
biggest things in the press about this
movie was like oh my god there's a sex
scene and i was like well that's way
more normal than killing millions of
people intimate love is a part of
existing so alarming to me like it's a
very very timid very like casual not
intense sex scene it's like they weren't
even having sex it's like they were just
laying on top of each other yeah no but
like it's even thrusting it's so weird
they're just but like every article's
like chloe put sex in marvel and i'm
like yeah but why is that weird and we
see people like catch on fire and burn
alive in iron man 3. we see half the
population go in but we can tell kids
you getting dusted and imagine a child
walking outside and thinking it's
possible for them to just be gone at
like seven years old and that be scarier
to them than two people [ __ ] [ __ ] you
you're raising your kids wrong so like i
really have a problem with the idea that
we've made because we were raised in
this prudish society america was founded
by puritans we pretend it wasn't we are
still in [ __ ] religious state we
still have a [ __ ] bible we swear on
in court which is [ __ ] this is still
a religious hierarchy we let [ __ ]
catholics little kids but we can't have
sex in a movie that's tasteful so it's
[ __ ] that you think that's a problem
and then you add to that like a loving
kiss between a man and his husband
that's raising a child and that's how he
connects to humanity this man invents he
creates he's an inventor of this world
that allows humanity to exist and you
have a problem with him kissing his
husband you're the problem he invented
gayness in this movie he invented the
game he isn't gays in the movie paperboy
finally did it they finally gave a
religious understanding all of the
conversations drive me [ __ ] crazy
because we're 20 21 we're so far into
society being we've we invented the
internet so long ago and we still have a
problem with [ __ ] that people had a
problem with in the 1920s grow the [ __ ]
up and enjoy the movie or not but don't
make that why you don't enjoy the movie
see i i mean
it's funny because right before you
jumped into that diatribe i hate bigotry
too bigotry sucks it's the worst and
it's but i was gonna sometimes
but that
that's where i draw the line
just don't put it to my face
no no no but but but uh aside from
bigotry which which sucks and i hate
that it has to be part of the
conversation and i hate that we have to
be like you know hooray for disney for
not censoring this which good for them
but also that shouldn't be an issue but
uh my favorite weirdly because people
will step up to me especially people who
don't like the movie as much like i feel
like there's a certain charge around
this movie where people want to
challenge you about your opinion and and
similar to your response whatever
somebody comes at me with that i'm like
sure okay because part of my favorite
aspect of this whole experience is that
it's super divisive and it is that it's
at a 50 on rotten tomatoes or whatever
and everyone disagrees and has their own
opinion and they're doing so not because
it's a bland and unambitious movie but
because it's a movie that tries a bunch
of stuff and you either like it or you
don't and i feel like this is the first
time we've had this experience with the
mcu truly
like this you know where it's like okay
this is kind of a different beast and
you either think it's succeeding or it's
not and i hope that they don't i think
they're smart enough not to take the
wrong uh take away from like the kevin
flag he's gonna be like let's not make a
think piece again because you know yeah
they're not gonna go look and be like
well people clearly liked thor the dark
world better i'm like well no i mean you
know it's maybe a little more competent
at doing less things than this movie is
trying to do you know i still think it
would have been a better show i
absolutely agree i personally think it's
i it was one of those things where i
couldn't help but think it could have
been it would have been a better show
because you really could have all those
things like would fast those with the
flashbacks i felt
there because so much of fast has this
influence on technology with humankind
right amazing
and
it's my issue that i was saying with the
flashbacks of like we just cut to the
thesis or the end moment it's like i
built the engine and then we cut to the
moment with druid later on
he's like your technology is ruining
[ __ ]
fastos and then we cut to hiroshima but
we don't see the experience of him
getting involved and and seeing like the
the any of that i know see here's the
thing i gotta say this though even when
i left the theater with john normally if
i have issues with a movie
i start to like kind of go well here's
what i think they maybe could have done
and they could have rewritten it to do
it and my honest opinion of why i just
don't hate this movie despite the way
how i ultimately didn't really feel much
from watching it is the fact that
i'm like well there's nothing else they
really could have done
for a movie there's nothing about it
they did the like that is about the most
they could compact into this movie
without it feeling like too much or even
though some people do feel like it's
over convoluted and very much rushed i'm
like are you kidding it's like the
slowest mcu movie that's ever exactly
no way rush
but they are jam-packing a lot so so the
reason why it could feel over convoluted
i think is because of those missing
beats of feeling like we're not getting
some real exploration moments that can
leave people feeling a little bit like
they're missing out on something in
particular something that koi does not
have the association with but people
like me
um
but uh yeah i mean so overall i still
kind of wish it was a show and i feel
like this could have been a show but
we've got to get to the question that's
been my gripe for for every every short
coming of the recent movies but yeah
it's questions time gonna hop into the
super chats quick shout out the nerd
upstairs says chloe did her best to make
a justice league movie which on the
second viewing i actually kind of
thought more of icarus is playing henry
cavill's superman
yeah and they shoot a lot of his solo
scenes like they're out of that movie
especially when he's gone the farm
visiting uh ajax
and uh anish tanjirullah says more of
dane whitman would have been nice you
know it's funny i i have often been kind
of like a kit harington skeptic and
pound for pound i think this is my
favorite kit harrington performance yeah
he was incredible across the board like
you know it's easy to like him because
you like jon snow eight seasons of game
of thrones but uh 20 minutes
oh yeah i'm like this is my favorite kid
it is because you know game of thrones
is good but he just has to show up and
do his jon snow broodie thing whereas
here i was like oh you're charming and
yeah yeah i mean no no i mean don't get
me wrong i thought kate harrington was
awesome in this movie yeah that line
that he has when he sees right run up
the stairs i'm running around the wall
and he's about to jump over and go oh my
god
that was perfect i love that he's the
human like he had to connect through
them through him and like it was just
genius casting he was perfect yeah
absolutely perfect absolutely all right
william jones first super chat of the
day thank you so much william jones says
nine out of ten happy that we finally
got a character story driven mcu movie
everything doesn't have to be all right
sorry guys camera coming back on we got
a cannon
thank you yes
does not everything does not have to be
all
actually i know we finally got a
character story driven mcu movie never
none of them ever have nobody i don't
know any of the other characters
i mean i'll say that this one clearly
its priorities are doing that stuff i
think it's yeah i mean don't get me
wrong i think that is the intent and i'm
really happy you feel that way
same score i gave i give it four and a
half out of five stars nine out of ten
that's a nine languages
i've officially decided
what would that be five and a half out
of ten is that
math make it sound better than it is
is all my appreciation for what they
were going for in tension you're half a
score from a d minus you're an f-plus
scott owen i just just gotta start
checking out
but i i mean i really have i started
checking out during the finale the
second time around the the finale i was
really checking with the big battles
yeah that's when i was like i'm really
not into this but the
but i was really focused for everything
you know what and i'm still on the same
opinion of like i really felt like they
could have had better written
conversations i i thought the debate
around humanity was coming down to do we
agree with our mesh or do we not agree
with our that's what it kind of all felt
like to me take some heat off greg here
yeah i think armageddon and the irishman
are two aggressively bad films
overrated in each of their categories
and actually one of them makes the
criterion collection less valuable to me
and the other one makes me doubt cinema
so see me enough greg now you can yell
at me help me bring it i know greg was
worried about saying that i just said it
out loud i said these eternals
i'm going to be honest no matter what i
just got to be honest
even though i know i'm going to get a
lot of crap it's good this makes for a
good segue because scott owen thank you
scott scott says personally like a seven
seven and a half for me really the first
and third act meh to me but the second
act was enjoyable you see it was weird
the second time watching it especially
watching on imax the second time around
i was like the first 25 minutes i i had
a thought of oh [ __ ] am i
was i way off the first time
do i really like this movie and then as
it progressed i wasn't really as super
into it and i do think that it does fall
that that finale does become like i
appreciate the choice what i really
appreciate about the finale is it's not
a build up to fight a super villain you
know what i mean like it's a moral
question because the finale is about
whether or not we're worth saving
like is it worth us surviving to
eliminate millions of other lives i
appreciate the question i i don't
appreciate the lack of exploration which
i know you don't feel know
we can disagree
this is a perfect sliding scale because
i'm over here in the corner going you
know this brought up a lot more themes
and topics than most every other
superhero movie i've seen and now i just
wish that i could see these discussions
play out do you see like i think my
opinion out of anyone on the internet
who who probably echoes mine in the most
efficient way would be jeremy john's
opinion which is why he's the best why
is he one of the biggest because uh i
was like yeah my opinions right there
and so is jeremy yeah therefore he's
doing a running mate why i resonate with
him the most
i do actually i do think it's important
audience that you find someone you
identify with more often and then follow
their stuff because the rotten tomatoes
i disagree with john's so often oh yeah
but in general i think attaching
yourself to someone who's got your
opinion is more important than rotten
tomatoes because rotten tomatoes isn't
the movie sixty percent rotten potatoes
doesn't mean it's 60 good it means 60
out of however many hundred reviewed it
gave it a pass fail it's a black and
white system that's been colorized it's
taking a photo that was shot in black
and white adding colors so it's more
approachable it's literally a boil down
but what i wanted to say though what i
think in terms of like hero versus
because i think
a lot of the times
what may what i honestly think may be
missing for
people who are used to typical marvel
films and this isn't really a
a super big hindrance to me like i don't
really care for this and it just kind of
occurred to me now um is that usually a
marvel movie has a build up to a finale
to fight a villain that's usually what
your build up is going towards right
yeah
and here it's not that it's like we got
to put the celestial to sleep here like
eventually get to pass an hour in then
you realize what their goal is they just
have to put it to rest
um
so what i appreciated with them at least
having their big blowout fight was that
they decided to use it to have the
icarus reveal and have the big fight be
within the conflict with icarus sprite
going up against that and getting and
what i thought was smart about it what
what i will credit the movie for on
making that choice
is
icarus the whole time he is seen as
don't mess with him he is invincible he
is the omni man of our team he is the
superman of our team he is our
homelander you cannot
no one can be don't even bother yeah
like don't even try because he's clearly
the one everyone's like oh thank god
icarus is here you know
they all call him boss half the time so
when he turns it does it does lead to
okay you need the eternals to work
together to take this guy down and then
at the end he has to join them yeah but
then makari just whoops his ass like
mccarty i was like [ __ ] we didn't even
like mccarty's the most powerful one
is like i can't i can't i can't you know
i thought i thought makari the way she
was brought to life reminded me of the
injustice flash yeah and and the way the
fight scenes were done that was [ __ ]
great and uh like that first the first
moment on the beach when she like [ __ ]
up hickory i just love the double reveal
of it's a triple reveal it's icarus and
he's just following orders he's not a
bad guy he's doing what they've been
told to do and that is so many problems
i believe is in the mission
and that's one of the things that have
so many problems with authority is
because so many times we look back at
our history and go oh [ __ ] if one person
hadn't just listened to authority that's
a longer suggestion the just following
orders thing is responsible for so much
of human atrocity across history having
someone above human have that decision
to be made that's a fascinating
commentary and that's what all these
characters are they're archetypes on our
decisions so that's one twist the
secondary twist of the deviance
effectively being what we could be if we
need aliens we are going to be the
lesser species because aliens got the
[ __ ] here we haven't gotten to them so
if and when we ever meet aliens we're
going to be smaller than so deviants
represent something sentient just trying
to survive and they're also just
following orders so deviants are
arguably with the right world view with
the white perspective the heroes of this
movie and then the third [ __ ] twist
being that the celestials which create
life are just trying to create more life
and we are fodder we are food we are
something to consume like the matrix
like a lot of other commentaries on us
so you've got three different
perspectives of villainy at the end of
the day we might be the ones that are
wrong but we think we're right because
that's human nature we always assume
we're correct while we're actively a
virus destroying this planet see i feel
like you have given significantly more
commentary towards that all those
subjects
than the movie actually did it's right
there every single if you if you like
extremely that's what i mean it's very i
felt like it just touches and it's very
like okay in the in the non-spoiler
review
the thing that i cut out and there's a
little bit that i made where i was like
i'm gonna cut this out and it was like
five minutes later you see coin like
arguing
it was about was about the deviance
specifically
i was like you do learn that the
deviants are essentially like uh they're
created from celestial so they're just
like the eternals in the sense that they
are just these things beings created for
something
of a purpose that they never asked for
in any regard and there be their pawns
are being used as well
and well and there was also having their
natural evolution be mitigated and
stomped upon so there was a i thought
there was a real
a time where i was like oh this is
interesting things you could do you
could really have a conversation here
about the fact that like these people
who we've been here for thousands of
years for mainly just to
kill these guys
we're a lot like them more than we
realize and they don't i really i saw it
twice and i'm two hours and five yeah i
looked out for it and you were saying to
me that they're there
what are you talking about as soon as he
gets a voice boys it's gonna be all
right what are you
i love sitting over here going man
everything greg's saying is like how i
feel about most of these movies and in
this movie i'm like you know yeah you
could have gone much further but they
went a lot further than a lot of other
ones so you're exactly in the middle and
but i'm like yeah like the deviant scene
i'm like my gripe is
it's one good moment
and and the rest of them is just that's
they serve the purpose of bringing it
those are three giant things you cannot
focus unless this was a trilogy which
you can't guarantee with box office you
can't get scheduling of all these actors
three times you can't guarantee this
gonna do well enough so what i liked is
that they made a trilogy in one movie i
would love a show it's not it's not it's
not i made a trilogy and one movie
sounds like they compacted too much in
one minute i would i i don't disagree
which is why it's not a tent but at the
same time i am sitting here at a
multiversal crossroads
where both of you are correct and i
agree with you both because
i want this to do one movie's worth of
well fleshed out [ __ ] but at the same
time i'm like but they did get these
three kind of gray conflicts into one
and they've done
what what you're describing martial has
done one well excuse me but i think i
can bite off more than you can chew
every so often and there's some dude in
the chat in the in the spoiler free that
was like koi's projecting a lot here art
is projecting you're experiencing what
you see the [ __ ] art as yeah so yeah
i think it's good that some people got
more i need to validate you both really
quick i need to validate you both faith
gettys in the chat loves greg's honesty
and appreciates it about the film and
jonas diaz agrees that the irishman is
overrated
another you both are pretty well i think
that's all we're here for i don't think
giving credit to other areas of this
movie does
disregards
what i what i consider to be a valid
criticism of what the movie lacks also
fair and not disagreeing with you i just
don't think it affected me as negatively
so it doesn't hurt my feeling on the
film because i was able to have my own
reading a comic is thinking about the
space between the panels every panel
you're interpreting in between that i
got enough to interpret the space
between the panels this didn't need to
be a six hour movie you didn't and
that's a-okay
but that's why i liked it more than you
because we both love a lot of the same
[ __ ] yeah i just felt like the deviants
i liked them more the first time i
watched them the second time around i
was like oh cause like the first four
times you see the deviants they're just
getting their asses handed to them like
the first four times i counted i was
like okay okay
every time and then by the time you get
to and i understand that like i was like
okay the movie is planning the seed so
that like when gilgamesh is finding a
deviant in the flashback that he he does
need help right he can't just do this by
himself so i was like okay smart on the
movie to do that yeah um but yeah i felt
like by the time they introduced this
big thing i'm like oh that to me the
movie's been about
the the main catalyst plot has been
eternals versus deviants i feel like i
really feel like the movie should have
added just a few more minutes to that
regardless
i could have done with another 20
minutes of this movie and that's the
issue is we've we've lived through 25
marvel films where whether you love them
or hate them you could say like oh it
was pretty well clear and spelled out
what we were trying to achieve i like
the fact that this movie is going to be
a conversation about whether it
registered or not i've never had a
conversation with you or was like did
this emotionally impact you or know i
don't think we could feel that way about
any other marvel movie yeah it's it's a
yes or no it's a worked or not this is
really interpretive because it's so bold
and all these people saying it [ __ ]
follows the mcu formula what [ __ ] mcu
formula are you watching this doesn't
have any origin story it's not the
hero's journey it's differently paced
it's arguably a five act structure like
a play everyone's saying it's like cut
and dry but slower like you watched a
different movie than me bro
and that's the magic of this film hey
jamie hutchinson was on track josh super
chat he was on track john really
another quick piece of validation for
for us uh hudson knight in the main chat
says just want to say i love greg and
john however adding coy to this channel
so often is straight fire
100 so heck
would catch fire hal is just sitting on
the side like
alice is going to be a crispy burnt up
and the first person on the desk is just
uncomfortably sitting there
i fought my way up to fighting a
one-on-one match with dan murrell and i
was like ma'am i've never fought cold i
beat dan three times i would like oh
[ __ ] yeah like that's why christian
brought me to the schmode and he thought
i'd be good but i'm awful at it
all right that's why i relate to you as
a manager all right jamie hutchinson
what did you think oh maybe i'll take
this one first jamie hutchinson because
this is something i found myself
appreciating a lot the second time was
what did you think of the editing of the
film and uh honestly this is a movie
where there are definitely times where
i'm like oh i feel i feel like something
got excised heavily from this part of
that part but for the most
part of my viewing experience especially
the second time i found myself very much
admiring
uh the
physical editing choices i'll say it's a
little muddier in terms of the overall
intellectual viewing experience but i
think the grace with which so many of
the scenes are stitched together through
motion through matching
through
just you know framing and whatnot i
think is really well planned out and it
really really lends credibility to all
the different effects whether they be
the wire effects whether they be the cg
effects the physical effects the
practical makeup effects like there are
especially things like lending
credibility to
icarus's flight and floating and things
like that where they're clearly like
panning around somebody on wires and
matching that to a new shot like i
thought a lot of the way that they
edited this helped to smooth the ways in
which they were filled uh folding the
story together you know it's like okay
here's a flashback and now we're jumping
back to the present and you're going so
many places and times in this movie that
i thought actually for the most part the
editing combined with the cinematography
was quite graceful and and quite poised
um so when them
aside from the times where i could
sense that oh yeah like that there was
something else here that was supposed to
fluidly connect whatever scenes
you know that sex scene was like god new
angle every half a second
man the fluids in the sex scene that's
what like everyone's acting like it was
like sex scene was great it was a crazy
wonder it was a crazy one shot nice long
warner in a hallway yeah see i i loved
the movies that uh
that capture this tone and the in this
pacing i really do and it's for me it's
like the
day if i'm not connecting with the
writing or the overall storytelling it's
just not really going to work for me but
i don't think the movie's edited poorly
i think i see a lot of people complain
about the pace and i'm like i don't
actually don't think the pace is the
problem personally as much as i'm on the
camp of like meh i don't think the pace
is a problem i do think there are some
moments that are what i call nolan
edited
where it's like like the scene when
icarus is here anyway
no no no no no not not sound design i'm
talking about
like this another pilot flying by over
my dialogue the the the scene when uh i
think it's the scene when icarus and
cersei are first like getting to know
each other you're beautiful holding
hands for the proposal
the way they're like cutting around
there is a little bit odd it feels like
nolan editing but i was thinking they
were going for a serial effect
yeah i was like there was a lot of
cutting happening here and there's a lot
of like skipping like two seconds skip
three seconds before like there's like
little moments of skipping it's like
jump cuts but with different shots
and
then uh sometimes the editing would no
towards the end
that time when uh faso says bye to druid
gives him the hug a moment i appreciate
it and then it just cuts to the ship
leaving yeah oh okay ship's leaving but
overall i don't think the movie in terms
of editing for what they had to handle i
don't think it's particularly i don't
think the pacing is the thing that is an
issue for me i made the mistake of
realizing the full live chats over there
and i glanced at it and i realized uh so
someone said koi is like listening to
stay on twitter in real life i want to
defend the fact that greg thought it was
like don't read the chat it's my job to
read the chat and pick up the flattering
questions
there's a reason we gave john the chat
but i've got i've got a thing to say
that's really pick the validating
comments
you see it as like an eight or seven or
eight seven and a half to eight yeah
five and a half five and a half to six
somewhere there so five to six seven
half to eight as an eight and a half to
nine person i'm defending the things i
experienced but by my defending them
with fact and logic and examples negates
your stand [ __ ] because sans just
say it was good for the sake of being
marvel a stand by their nature are above
a fanatic it is based on the eminem
concept of being a stan someone that's
such a fanatic they become fanatical and
stalking i mean you had a defensive
vodka on the way
so like i would argue i'm giving you
different experiences
and therefore i'm not a stan i'm not a
stan so i just want i'm saying what i
liked about it with examples so don't
give me that [ __ ] hell's yeah all righty
all righty hey quick quick one from the
live chat bright t says you three are
the you to mind of movie reviews let
your forces be combined and i like that
metaphor especially for this movie
because the uni mine half the time picks
up people who aren't even on board like
in the finale they're like it's a good
thing unimine picked up icarus because
holy [ __ ] guys
anyway pandemic jones
love you pandemic jones over at the
patreon shouts out i thought it was good
as far as mcu origin movies it's in the
top for me i thought pretty much each
eternal had a badass moment the real
debate though who had the more
attractive cast dune or eternals
a knight's tale
oh dude
dude oh my god rebecca ferguson you just
can't top her she's yeah it's hard to
top her it's hard to talk rebecca
tiernan is like such a like an ethereal
beauty and then you add an injury too
unattainable for me
but rebecca ferguson isn't a guitar i
could turn like a rebecca
feels so terrible because i have looked
up the um
the actress who plays makari her name is
so many times yeah i keep for slabbering
he's living because i see her as makari
because it's my first introduction
but like all of them sexual about the
dune cast there's something very
like roland oscar isaac
like like timmy chalamet definitely
wants to [ __ ] everybody yeah there's
anyone there's a [ __ ]
yeah but it's reciprocated even he's
like
guarding them he's just like i'mma ride
in this one of six
richard madden with his scot accent
you've got uh my boy barry with his
irish accent you've got a lot more like
there's a lot more going on with worldly
culture and like that that's sexy to me
like there's definitely i i feel like
[ __ ] this cast you'd learn more about
yourself it's the eternals cast is
definitely if you ever get a chance to
[ __ ] this cast you're going to [ __ ] this
kid you're going to learn a lot about
yourself would you [ __ ] the dune cast
you get santa i think it depends on the
uh i think it depends on um your sexual
orientation really or your sexual
preferences i would rather have sex in
the locations for maternals that's for
damn sure both are sandy one seems like
it's more hospitable yes yes i'm gonna
go with turtles and i wouldn't have
thought that until i'd seen the movie
because i kept saying dune was i think
it turned out i don't know we got james
chan angeline jolie come on guys you've
got selma hayek
come now richard come now
barry kehoe i guess we're sure man kate
harrington i finally learned how to say
that guy's name and i'm not gonna tell
either of you how it works
but the doom cast is one of the sexiest
of all time assembled great question
because it is actually very tricky yes
yes koi's rating of iran was about eight
and a half to nine for this movie p plus
a minus anyway
poven meyer povenmir
thoughts on batman and superman
reference oh you better believe there
are thoughts on the batman superman
references seemed weird to me that they
referenced two of their competitors
biggest characters but also
at least one of those characters is an
inspiration for one of these characters
well i think uh
it's not it would be weird if they were
like
if they referenced i don't know dark
side or something like that that's when
i think it would be weird batman and
superman are such a big part of i mean
hey that kind of eliminates the whole
thing i mean it doesn't really because
it could just be dc comics exist in this
world um
but it doesn't eliminate the possibility
maybe dc marvel could cross over it it
doesn't cause they didn't reference it
exactly very clearly we'll see what
happens yeah but okay the first time
it's referenced is the alfred thing and
then at first i was like ah that's cute
and then they do the superman i'm like
wait
and the premiere i remember being there
when they said superman it was followed
with a it was a laughter followed by a
wait what's going on right now like
everyone in the audience is like what's
going on what are they doing this is the
two right now everyone became hyper
aware of it and then the week later the
rock was on a red carpet saying i've
been talking to deadpool and wonder
woman and we're trying to make this
happen i'm not tin foil hats what i do
but like this doesn't seem like they set
them as fiction or non-fiction which i
think zou zhao came out and talked about
how this this whole story is an
embodiment of just hero mythology so
like referencing them was very
intentional in that regard because i
think at the end of the day
you know you probably put spider-man up
there but i feel like there's no two
comic book characters
i'm not talking about their films or
whatever like that's not a debate about
that batman and superman just exceed a
whole new era of iconography
in pop culture medium energy everyone
in the world
knows of batman and superman everybody
said you're not superman you know yeah
yeah said that
so like it's always kind of that
commentary yeah but i also hope they
show up i'm not going to be cool if they
have one day they're going to have this
the dc can exist so they're going to
have to so in the live chat i'm just
noticing a lot of people would would
smash the dune cast first respect mr
vaju over here is a is going for the
goat saying hated dune hated eternals
hated venom two awesome for you
he does not enjoy going to the movies
don't go to the movies and somehow play
chess
and erica just wishes koi saw the
glimpses of all the love we are giving
him here
this is how the internet works you catch
the one comment that hates you and you
ignore all the rest let's do one more
super chat and then we'll hop over to
the stream labs because we got something
over there as well we've got to start
getting focused on these guys we got to
be a little more efficient derrick's
derek sword can you guys please react to
the fan made video called an undying
promise it's a compilation of snyder's
dc films with great editing and music
the thing at the end there is probably
the main reason why we cannot guarantee
something like that because uh
especially fan-made edits are awesome
but they often rely on popular music
which will get us demonetized in a jiffy
and already koi's
lucrative amount of sex talk here has
got in this live stream do you monetize
this
it was tasteful said nothing out of
pocket
what have i said it is far from tasty it
has not even gotten in cc
hey someone asked i didn't say that out
of nowhere it was questioned upon me
that's a secret is there an anti-sex
youtube thing
i mean yeah yeah you talk about yeah
yeah really they don't like we're like
this is a miracle
what i'm saying
you can shoot a guy in the head and
that's fine but if you talk about a
thing that actually creates man instead
of killing it it's a problem we live in
america where that's way more problems
[ __ ] more fight less i would much rather
you go out and clobber a stranger than
make love
hey
curtis mason on the stream labs thank
you so much there is a pinned link up
there all contributions are very much
appreciated streamlabs just takes a
little less cut off the top uh just saw
eternals curtis mason says last night
fun movie but i think
a lot of casual fans might get confused
perhaps it would have been better as a
disney plus show with how much info is
in it i'm interested to hear your guys
uncensored thoughts on the movie well
you're here you're you're doing it now
the uncensored thoughts are happening
uh yeah what i would say really quick is
that um okay since we already talked so
much about this extensively
i'm gonna throw another hat in the ring
here we gotta put a timer on this we
gotta answer some of these questions all
right we gotta be we gotta be respectful
here
i don't feel like richard madden and
gemma chan
they had almost no chemistry for me
and it really bothered the hell out of
me and don't you [ __ ] say that shit's
intentional they were together for five
thousand years
i'm gonna say that i must say i have
some chemistry one of my only negatives
in the film was that i'm okay all right
i saw you i saw the hackles yeah one of
my only negatives of the film is i
completely bought her and kit harrington
and i know you needed to buy that more
because it's the it's the it's the
conflict but if you don't buy the other
at all you're like well just go be with
kid harrington
like so the the love triangle was more
of a love rectangle because i was just
like i was like their dynamics of when
they fell in love don't feel all that
different to me when they're not
so yeah that was a problem i really feel
like they had it's like you guys have
been together for 5 000 years i don't
even feel like you guys dated for six
months i feel like the audience had more
sexual tension with richard madden than
cheated i feel like everyone was like ah
and like just brooding and on the brink
of sweat every scene
that that whole that i think his
character trait was if i don't blink
that's my character
just don't blink but i agree and that is
one of my negatives i'll i'll maintain
that don't lose faith ibrahim khan we're
gonna jump back to the super chats asap
but we do gotta check out the stream
labs as well dan v i liked eternals but
it had quite a few issues i feel like
i'm the only one who noticed all the
traveling in one day
before they got the domo there's no way
they'd make it
in time honestly it was just regular
play yeah it was just a regular plane
they were on uh
on night six read all over the world not
believable and then dan v goes on to say
some hayek wasn't very good as ajax and
was miscast i don't believe what she was
saying uh
what's over and whatsoever whatsoever
sorry and sorry it's so far away
yeah
and she didn't have the gravitas with
her words
jeffrey wright or rebecca ferguson would
have been more believable in the role
not great uh keep going up yeah damn
damn v you really took advantage of the
ending it was incredibly abrupt and it
made it feel like the film wasn't
complete just to set up a sequel i
didn't buy leah mchugh as sprite as this
old soul compared to
uh aidan gallagher as number five in
umbrella academy where i buy that he's
an old man the pacing wasn't great the
deaths weren't impactful there just
wasn't oh my god there's a there's a lot
here okay he's got thoughts the deaths
weren't impactful there just wasn't a
lot of chemistry with the cast other
than gilgameshino where don lee was
under you okay this guy's echoing a lot
of my opinions at least that's one good
thing about slow down
i like makari and drink together but not
madden and chan gingo and the valet were
standouts i wanted to see the
documentary that pip cgi was atrocious
we definitely got to talk about that not
showing rehearsal on the on camera where
he just needed a black shirt and
sunglasses this would be like not sure
at the end of uh
uh i have one one iron man one
and the last thing a movie like mask of
the phantasm was far better with its
placement of flashbacks makari's
character was underutilized and i
couldn't remember her name had to google
her after the deviants weren't necessary
we got a superman flash fight though
okay i i definitely agree with you on a
decent amount of this um
let's go back to the first point about
what was he saying about selma hayek
specifically being miscasted
i liked her because she needed to be she
was a maternal she represented like
mother nature maternals
maternals yeah i liked i thought somehow
i did a good job that's one thing i i i
can't meet you there um i thought i
showed up she brought like the passion
and the choice for the because you have
that scene with aramesh early on where
she's like
aramesh you know i'm kind of feeling
these [ __ ] it's these humans these
humans are like the [ __ ] you know i'm
maybe he's like don't forget the plan
and then later on my issue from a plot
standpoint
this was my issue from a plot standpoint
absolutely it was
you mean to tell me you waited
six days until this is gonna happen to
be like
we gotta stop this you had thousands of
years to think about this
thousands upon thousands of years just
found out she just found out what she
told icarus when they left babylon yeah
chris was the bad guy he wanted it to
happen but i'm saying they had without
she's trying to stop it she knew this
was always going to happen yeah but she
didn't realize like that they were
causing it to be the like fuel they
thought they could save people
so wait what are you talking about
cersei only found out hey jack i'm
talking about ajax ajax wanted us to die
i feel like ajax was cool with it i i
feel like
ajax is the one who tells icarus
directly we have to stop that's why
that's why richard madden kills her yeah
you're right i take it back i thought we
were talking about cersei this whole
time i didn't know you were talking
about you're right
i've had a lot of children
reading the chat
god damn stop getting in your head in
the chat it's my fault i i when i was
the second time i watched it i'm like
why'd you wait thousands of years and
why are you and
it's so obvious to me like the one
person who's not gonna be on your side
on this one is gonna be icarus why are
you confiding in icarus specifically
about this and why did you take out like
that from a plot standpoint i'm like
this is this isn't like something you
just learned this has been thousands of
years you've had time to think about
this
and so that that was the one part of the
plot i'm like you should have you should
you could have come up with a plan ages
ago
even like a year ago you had to plan to
come up with this should we talk post
credit scene while i mentioned pip yeah
yeah let's let's let's go to the very
end of his and yeah let's talk about pip
let's talk about the post credits
talking post credit scene at this point
uh spoilers for a movie we've been
talking about for an hour but uh pip
was uh a terrible cgi patrol but i like
the scenes i do i love the scenes i do
agree that like and pat also owns a
great pit i think pat and oswald as pip
is a good choice yeah but i do feel like
it was some phase two cgi
uh and i also love but cgi it looked
like butt but i also i truly think harry
styles is a perfect arrow star fox
because the guy you want to love harry
styles by default so anytime he's like a
treacherous betrayer you're gonna be
like i believe to do harry styles uh so
i i think it's perfect it also is a
really smart way to bring in a new
audience a lot of people that are like
harry styles stans are gonna immediately
fold into whatever weird cosmic entity
movie it might educate some people that
aren't necessarily reading uh into a
different broader world view i'm one of
the biggest harry styles fans that never
knew he was in one direction uh i've
been a big i owned two harry styles
albums and found out a month ago he was
in one direction and had a big ol
epiphany i think he's a genius and he's
one of the best
in the world to treat his fans and to be
the forefront of moving things forward i
think he's really using his fame and his
brand and his nests to allow us to
progress as a culture so for him to be
in marvel gives me a lot of hope for his
audience who's very progressive and
who's very aware of things needing to be
changed to fold into the mcu uh while
simultaneously having when he betrays us
feel extra zesty love you
he's like
he's like the next perhaps more talented
actor justin timberlake perhaps he's
like justin guy who came from a boy band
went solo got more popular lovable
interviews and stuff became an actor god
started getting taken seriously as an
actor now going down the actor path
because i personally never go i never
got into one direction
um
but i yeah i mean
uh but i but i but i think harry styles
is a really good actor and i and i
really liked his scene there and in
terms of who the arrows character i
think the thing is if you don't know
eros which i don't really know eros i i
like
gauntlet that was about it that but
if you don't know eros at all
if you hear thanos brother and that's
all you know
if you hear if you hear thanos brother
that's all and that's all you know is
like oh he's thanos's brother and then
you i think in here harry styles i can
see why some people might have a
negative connotation because they don't
you would probably imagine how can this
guy be thanos's brother right because
they don't realize that no aeros is well
wildly different yeah
very intentionally yeah yeah and uh
you've seen his concert stuff like he
he's like his performances he's like
pulling people he's amazing he helps
people come out like people hold up
signs and he's like my mom's i've seen
him in a lot of interviews he's just so
good yes now the question becomes do
they bring bts into the universe i hope
so they they name-checked them
but uh a new team and then the blade
moment oh i loved it so [ __ ] much coy
did you know that was blatant yes
immediately oh my god we were all like
this jeffrey right we thought it was no
we were all surrounded by a group of
people that are this is why you guys
should have brought me into your
screening because it was obviously mar
hashanah now in fairness uh i i went to
like he was an acting studio for a bit
so like i know maher challa's voiced
really well because like we've acted
opposite each other almost name drop wow
but it's just a fact it's the context of
his voice like when i hear his voice
it's i know that voice well how else do
i explain about name dropping how does
it feel
to know that he's
blade
and you're on the real rejects
did you know that i was doing a play
with alden when he found out he was han
solo oh
what
same acting studio i've succeeded that's
not the same thing no i'm saying i'm
saying i'm so beautiful i've just gone
those two are in the same studio with me
they've done better kevin feige here i
am on the real rejects loving this no no
i'd rather be here i'm about to be here
if if there's anything about la's you're
constantly surrounded by people who
you're like
man my friends are more successful
but you know what i don't do i don't
have to repeat myself on camera i like
this i like hosting more and i'll get
that carson daily money one day anyway
the point being
is so iconic and his voice is so clear
and the the ebony blade is so tied to
like the midnight sun's darker side of
marvel that to me it made sense i
actually the article came out that uh
friend a friend of mine ash did the
confirmation interview and everybody's
like oh my god that was him and i was
like i thought that was a three week old
news story like i had no idea people
didn't know oh dude it blew our minds we
just learned the other day you just
heard it yesterday that's why we didn't
talk about it because i thought it was
just like two days ago yeah we it's
because we had just finished watching
um what if he sounds so different than
jeffrey wright his voice isn't like it's
an octave
in three words when you hear three words
and it's off camera and it's someone
watching why i named him
that's why i named him because i don't
have contacts it's going to be jeffrey
right no i've never know she's jeffrey
moshey
who didn't go to our active
i just heard silence throughout all
those watcher monologues on what if
anyway moshi moshi's up next
people went to this expecting gundam but
got eva i assume you mean evangelion uh
and don't know how to process it hell
even had an impact in the middle of the
film i thought i was watching an anime
it has similar themes and structure as
varying series and movies i adored it
yeah like anime show
a lot of info dumping
show series
25 episodes
i'm glad you it really clicked for you
i also like your metaphor between gundam
and eva because that's fair and i think
that's really important to assess like
how you go into a thing this was also
advertised appropriately the trailer
showed a conversation kind of film you
know what i really love is is the is i
think mike doesn't have a good blast
okay and i think and i think i'm sorry
it's it's this if it keeps going i mean
if somebody wants to go into my backpack
and get my multi-tool we can fix it it's
the amount of flaccid it just won't stay
turgid
here's the youtube dynamization my my
mic won't stay my mic sounds nice i want
it to be tumultuous
lev flabulous doran i like to turtles
only thing for okay so open the front
pouch and at the bottom uh there's a
there's a little i just need it to last
more than four hours to consult my
doctor flev i liked eternals only thing
for me to love it was that i needed more
as someone who loves marvel uh driven
someone who loves character-driven films
sorry i loved it from that perspective
and plot was a basic end of the world
heroes gotta save it in my opinion a
character-driven film i agree with love
dorian i'm with you so yeah i mean i it
definitely kind of grapples between the
two
[Laughter]
it definitely grapples a bit uh between
the two but i appreciate that this is
perhaps the most earnest to me effort
that they've done in the mcu of doing
something that truly seems like it
it's committed to being sort of a
character thing first
uh even though it has all the big action
[ __ ]
and i actually liked the talking more
than the action there were times i was
like this action scene could have been a
minute shorter for a minute more talking
and that's not how i usually feel like i
i would absolutely make that trade yeah
like and that's and i think that's why i
like loki so much more than a lot of
these action-based shows is loki got
into like some strange existential
ponderings and this does too but i feel
like because this was a movie it felt
like it had to jump to an action set
piece so i would have preferred to show
as well i'm with greg on that and
flabbed oregano yeah i think uh
especially when they're like the second
time they cut to the flashbacks
like the second time you see athena i'm
like man this is the second this is the
second this is the second flashback with
ena and all she's doing is fighting
well i think like they really could have
just done a thing where okay
this you know how like the marvel
netflix shows would have an episode that
usually like it was episode three or
four they usually tell like an origin
tale yeah of how they got there so i'm
like yeah you just do like one episode
that was like mainly like druid focused
one episode that was mainly
so with druid i got a question um
actually no we gotta focus on the
questions
do you ever know but i will get to the
question remind me of
a druid ponder that i had the first
druid super chat well yes yes so
danvy is back a big no problem a big
problem is that people don't get how to
read rotten tomatoes i agree with you
the percentage just counts positive and
negative reviews the average rating gets
ignored which is far more important
eternals has a higher than average
rating than venom a higher average
rating than venom two with five point
six versus five point four out of ten
from critics and i mean [ __ ] i gotta be
on ryan
and i think that's a great point because
because the thing is you like everyone
says like oh this is the lowest rated
mcu since thor the dark world and i feel
like that headline misleads the the you
know just the initial reaction you have
is oh so it's worse than that movie but
you know rotten tomatoes you have to
cruise the capsules and maybe even then
read the full review because that's
where all the nuances lie because every
review is boiled down to a number and
then applied to the tomato meter are you
saying just reading a sensationalized
headline is bad for our culture it could
be okay studies have shown we should
look into that
i don't know heroes write another
that's where i get all my opinions i
think uh i think what happens to with
this whole attack running tomatoes
things all people reading are capsules
now are there a couple of reviews on
there that i've read from like dude i
wouldn't say like that's [ __ ] weird
so many things
are like what did you see there's
there's a couple of like full i've read
through a lot of the full reviews and
i'm like if you just read the capsule it
sounds like this person just hates it
but then a lot of times if you click on
the reviews they're like they're
definitely more nuanced than what the
[ __ ] capsule is so a lot of people
it's become this like it's this process
it's like the number is the most boiled
down and then the capsule is next to the
second most boiled down and then if you
actually go read a review that's the
real nuances it's funny that like dc had
this war would run to here that's right
so long
this is marvel this is the mcu's first
experience i tweeted it man like the the
idea that we made this ron tomato score
no marvel vs dc thing that's why i'm
worried about every election going
forward like our tribalism is terrifying
i hope marvel takes the the whole rotten
tomatoes of this as a win that's all i'm
saying
fund me it's good to see you again fun
me
love ya patron other otherwise 7 out of
10
rating makari better than quicksilver
that captured her powers so well loved
snyder influence pumped for blade and
black knight absolutely yeah well i
think because the actress who plays
mccarthy for not knowing do you know her
name john you look it up
two minutes
it's funny i don't know why i can't
retain it because i you know i got that
i'm attracted to her
but i think the benefit of having an
actual cruise
who is actually
sorry lauren ridloff
i was very compelled by her presence
the thing is like she has the kind of
performances that i most love on screen
where there's so much going on and
because of the fact that she's
um deaf is she deaf and mute in real
life i believe so but i don't know for
sure okay i'm sure she's she's deaf and
the fact because of that all she has to
really rely on is her body language her
facial expressions to really communicate
a full performance
and i love when
that's why i love ryan gosling so much
is i think he's so good at that yeah and
um and i feel like she really has that
capability
which is which i love seeing it on on
the big screen because like she's had
that she has this unfortunate situation
but she's managed to make something
beautiful out of it and um
yeah so i thought i i think mccarran is
great in the film i love the energy she
brings the presence she has a lot of she
brings a surprise amount of nuance to
that character who doesn't have that
much screen time did you know that her
druid wasn't in the script it was just
uh barry kihon's uh chemistry with her
he's like what i want to do
they literally were like they were on
set and there was like this friction and
they like wrote it in we can't get these
two off each other let's just film it
i think that's really true actually
because i did walk away having that as
my favorite uh roommate relationship
yeah and that was all improv based it
was literally out of the the scripts it
wasn't ever involved and then it
happened shouts out barry was making
moves on angelino wasn't panning out
it's that it's dangerous to have these
on set things
uh hey everybody thank you everybody uh
in the chat for getting lauren ridloff's
name and somebody i forget i'm sorry
i've forgotten who who posted this but
someone wants coy to direct eternals too
yes
i want to see what director coy is like
oh and there's a continuation from flev
shazbot you must have like gotten
squinched putting them in at the same
time but um uh flev goes on to say it
works best when you follow their
adventures and because we spent so much
time in character building we didn't
have time for the adventure part with
all of them together this is a
multi-part story and can't wait for the
next one i'm i'm really excited for
internals too i really hope we get more
it would be nice it would be nice
absolutely i mean i i've heard them say
that as just a sequel movie isn't
necessarily what they had planned but
the characters will go on so that
sounded like a thing that they were just
saying because they were like ooh these
reviews were bad yeah yeah definitely
press releases yeah
i can see that haskell forces
no it hurts me that's one of the reasons
i'm defending it so hard haskell 420 hey
greg and john and corki mercs manager
coy cast koi cubed host and of the koi
pond leader koi
your title has grown so long i saw this
on thursday and friday i really enjoyed
it even with uh its issues this was so
different and feels so much more uh and
feels so much more could have been done
to make this better uh makes me wonder
if uh it makes me wonder why feige let
it all alone let me help you yes left it
all alone because pretty much everyone
but him recognize a lot of wrong in this
uh how do you know that anyway
one of the most oh my god epic shots in
any film was of
aishon
eresham ersham
that is what it says but i think he
means there from the other who is it
what is it what is irish
overlooking earth and the people
freaking the [ __ ] out i so need that
post i think the use of arashim is
beautifully done like the first time you
see arishim when salma hayek she's just
like on his face yeah i do yeah you're
like what is she talking to yeah and
then that hand later when you're just
like you realize the scope of you and
then when she's uh because they build up
how much they show of irish him and his
involvement and like when he
actually you
know i thought i thought it really
worked it was it was scary but the
second time i watched it i thought of
the end of mortal kombat
when uh dawn shows up
when his face appears it grabs them it
really and it's all going cloudy and
dark with this big figure that was
direct inspiration it really looked like
mortal kombat to me at the end except
not as cheesy hell yeah and it wasn't
cheesy at all in internals but yeah i
thought the the scale and the
proportions of irish and the attention
of decent i love how like i didn't
notice until i saw an imax how he's a
little bit like rusted at times in his
wolf body figure which leaves the
impression of like battle wounds or
scars or just like he's not just here
doing you know god like
he's getting involved in some fights
once in a while you know so that's the
gundam movie we're gonna get he's he's
in a fight club
cory
cory once no never corey wants to know i
totally agree or or says i totally agree
with greg that eternals would be better
as a show thank god someone in here i
still love the movie
also regarding the eternals and thanos
how are arrows and thanos related if the
eternals are synthetic beings is thanos
in eternal also you guys are awesome
thanks corey in the comics is is thanos
not half deviant he's half deviant which
is how they're related which allows eros
to be more
handsome uh they're like it's more like
a half brother thing and and there's a
there's not as direct a correlation um
between between looks in family in that
in that world
yeah they didn't grow up like gamora
nebula no
different situations
hopefully that answers the question but
yeah they're they're they're half
brothers and also uh deviant blood is a
different entity but also the the power
and stuff does translate i see admiral
arv in the chat wants to know if anybody
thought this movie was shakespearean
which i'm just gonna throw out to the
chat chat cause that's a fun question i
feel like this movie borders on that but
does it get there
joe march attempts i think i think it
lands it has a big yeah
that's the thing that's the thesis
points
of opinion i think it attempts i think
this is so fun to be in the middle of
i always want you guys to have this
dynamic when we do this
and i'm over here like i can see where
you both are coming from man
get ready for a spider-man no way home
review oh golly
joe marge i think i think i'm gonna like
it more than you honestly
i'm gonna hate it the table is my turn
i'm gonna come out and be like guys this
was two photos
telling me everything showing me nothing
i hear it is the same run time as a
turtle zone it's a little longer it's
two minutes longer yeah that two minutes
could have been dedicated to fleshing
out a conversation with the tvs it's a
two-minute scene with theena you know
share runtime joe marge joe marsh
thank you coy for always speaking your
truth and thank you real rejects for a
positive discussion where people can
disagree and not be anuses i can go [ __ ]
himself i mean it's not unfold
making choices welcome to the internet
have a look around
left oren my two cents about the
character cersei uh cersei is such a
down to earth though down to earth oh
oh
cause they came down from the domino
she's such a down-to-earth vulnerable
person dane was great in his short time
sprite was annoying get her frustrations
but she's seven thousand years old so
she should be more mature
can go but she's trapped man she's in a
torturous position she's a torture
position
for seven years she's got fomo
yeah you're just doing that it's just
like a kingdom
if anything my issue with icarus is you
mean to tell me after 7 000 years you
haven't developed a personality
maybe he had one in the first thousand
years he got down and then he got jaded
before everyone else so much crap to
sprite not being annoying people give so
much this is such a common consensus and
i'm like well why don't you apply this
to icarus and be like you mean to tell
me this whole time this guy's barely
learning to fully smile
second viewing seven thousand years he's
got barely a personality on second
viewing sprites motive like sprites pov
became one of the most clear character
threads to me which is i i find this
interesting but uh uh and five goes on
to say i didn't foresee icarus uh not
being superman but actually being a
homelander druid reminded me of cro
we caught him we did the first trailer
we saw the trailer i was like that guy i
think is totally bad guys yeah we got so
mad at us there were so many comments
like you can't be the bad guy why would
he be and i'm like the trailer kind of
feels like he's a bad guy on my worst
days i'm like i'm gonna screenshot these
back to you druid reminded me of
credence from fantastic beasts for some
weird reason and fast house was great
that's not a bad correlation not at all
but it sucks that my mind went to oh
people will go bananas at that one scene
i see here's so interesting i want to
see one theater that when the kiss
happens everyone just like starts
cheering and like losing their minds
just like going crazy we're all in la
and i and i accept that this is a
different bubble and i accept we're in
that world but i am still alarmed
whenever it's even a conversation
because it's so not a thing well you
know what's funny is la i will not say
who i spoke with please don't i don't
want you i i had a very big discussion a
lot a lengthy discussion about this and
it was really debating it never got
heated so i was really trying to
understand how this person has like a
lot of
they have gay friends they have gay
family i'm a fife uh i [ __ ] am a
fight man
i love you emma i use that name because
i know what it's like
surgery we're just talking so much
those two
i was talking with this individual and
this person was saying how
they like i hate when that they make it
so overt and they're trying to push it
and i was like how are they pushing that
they felt like if anything it was a real
discussion it didn't become a
hate-filled thing
and then
it's like well you gotta understand
it's not normal to see that in a movie
i'm like but isn't that the point to
kind of help normalize these things but
not is so it's just being this whole
conversation about it
where
i truthfully don't believe this
individual i spoke with after having a
lengthy discussion like a lot of people
know this about me i identify as
bisexual and he knows that he's known me
for this person's know me for he would
narrow it down this person's known me
for for years this individual and uh
we've been friends for years and never
had an issue and has asked stories about
it was never had an issue with me yeah
and
has other gay friends and stuff but for
some reason
because i think of this person's age and
where they grew up whenever they see
like a gay kiss it kind of makes them
uncomfortable
it's just so it to me 2021 i can't
fathom that i can't put myself in their
shoes anymore
like i don't know what that would feel
like because i don't understand i mean
maybe it's because i'm a burner maybe
it's because i love drugs maybe i'm in
the culture more but i can't understand
at this point in our society seeing that
and being like that's weird it's not
right it's it's not so so i mean it's
like it's so interesting to know that
there are some people
there are some people just straight up
bigots and homophobes i don't feel bad
for those people i feel bad for whoever
this is you're talking yeah yeah um
and i'm looking at the chat it's not who
you think i'm talking about by the way
there's some people who i'm like that's
not what i'm talking about um
uh but yeah there are there are and i've
had this discussion with another person
too where this was the feeling that that
happens to them and it's it becomes this
introspective conversation of like
why because because i would bring up
like well that's kind of what's been
happening with race as well there's a
time where if like you saw an asian lead
they would have to just it's like how
cool is it now that we can have a gay
person and not make it about like
gay struggles or being gay like it's
just a thing about them yeah like they
wouldn't be distracted if it was two
women kissing right because you're used
to that you've probably seen them you'll
just be distracted in a different way
you've probably seen a pornographer
you're probably like that's fine but if
it's two guys why does it call attention
so it becomes a conversation and i like
i'm okay with having this discussion if
if it actually becomes a discussion and
not a
tragedy not to change my opinion like
literally tries to become an
understanding and then if if
if the person doesn't i like that i like
i like having a difference of opinion if
we can talk i'm also to the point where
like the you know the joke we just made
about two women is it it's i think it's
a thing about like 80s and 90s kids is
we had like so much pop culture that
featured women kissing as a sexualized
thing and not any pop culture but two
men kissing and now it's to the point
where even women kissing even if it's
not a hyper sexualized thing it is
hypersexual and then two men is like
this aggressively pushed out thing and i
hope that changes with things like this
property with things like eternals where
it's just people that love each other it
shouldn't be hypersexual or not sexual
we shouldn't be talking about a very pg
sex scene we shouldn't be talking about
a very normal kiss between husbands so
like the idea so that's what i'm
speaking to is i don't i don't feel bad
for the people that are just outwardly
like hate mongers they can rot in hell
but i do feel bad for people that just
don't feel like it's normal like that
must feel alienating to be around people
that that don't understand you and like
i hope they figure their [ __ ] out
because i remember being younger i think
i was like 14 and the first time i ever
saw in real life
two guys kiss wasn't like i i was in a
car with someone and i saw two guys
kissing in west hollywood and i'll admit
like it was a little jarring it was
jarring to me because i had never seen
two guys he first did something right
yeah and
but i'm like i'm 31 now so i'm like i'm
not like
like what the [ __ ] and honestly there
was a point too when when people clapped
at it there's a part of my cynical brain
that went off of like why are we
clapping i'm like this is so nice no one
clapped in my theater and i i wonder
what direction that is um i i i stormed
out the first no
no it's one direction
i was wondering why are people clap and
it took me a second to be like well okay
this this this clap is not for
me you know like because for people i
feel seen i'm like this is normal to me
and and i'm not like the [ __ ] for
thinking it's normal i was just like
this is just so normal to me yeah can we
get some congratulations in here for
greg yeah come on this is for greg
corey ross in the chat i'm so sorry i
think i did uh skip
upward because there was a corey before
you what do you think what do you want
to see from eternals moving forward do
you think we should see more flashbacks
from their time on earth in a potential
sequel i think
with characters who have been around for
thousands of years you could always show
some relevant flashback if it helps
bolster their character and uh overall
motivation
my my favorite part of flashbacks was
after seven thousand years when icarus
sees cersei at the end
all the flashbacks are just from the
beginning of the movies
yes you mean to tell me there's not one
new flashback you could have shot
hanging out for just a flash now it's a
little bit of a moment
it's like when it's like
they do that's a movie cliche though oh
when you show your own movie when you're
just like you mean to tell me there was
like nothing else that happened only
flashbacks from the movie they just
happened yeah they just met
rocky's driving over the death of a ball
of creed it's only from the first three
rocky iv is just flashbacks about rocky
rocky iv is my favorite flashbacks on
its own flashbacks in cinemas rocky is
my favorite cinema guys november 11th we
should all go but i i do got to say
director's guide love to go i would love
to see a fandango thing do that um but i
do gotta say though the use of the word
beautiful made sense to me
um because of when he he goes back to
the i like how that flashback ended on
the very first time he met her or at
least when he thinks he met her the very
first time he met her and and said like
you're it's beautiful talking about the
earth and he the word he learns
uh that when there's a joke out of it
when he says i am beautiful in whatever
language that is yeah like the
correlation of like she is earth yeah
you know yeah so
even though i don't get misty eyed or
teary i removed in the way you were i'm
not gonna like you okay i get this
moment and i get why the flashbacks end
on that specific that's fair point of
like she is earth she is the she is
beauty and she's fighting for this so
yeah i like that earth
do we have some super chats oh we got
helicopters
here we go let's let's power up guys all
right let us power up this money's going
to come
oh sure here let me find out where we
are first because i've been a minute
we've been a minute let's put out a new
poll okay october oh yeah
all right what's the new question to put
out
so we we've we've been able to hit my
vape are you guys okay with that i'm
always self-conscious about my videos
live your life don't worry about it what
is self-conscious about it is there
crack in there just weed
what's a problem
all right we're ending this poll 43 of
everyone loved it 37 liked it
16 thought it was a meh and four percent
are you guys gonna react to the no way
home poster no
way
yes is there no way home poster out is
there a new one a new one all right
what's the new poll gee what's the new
poll
favorite character
oh i like that druid i got to put in 10
options though
type them up i feel like spiderman no
way home will be [ __ ] booming on
twitter right now if there was a new
post yeah that's that's the thing maybe
it happened
also if you smoke crack i got no
judgment just in case there's any
crackheads in the audience
live your life see somebody outside the
7-eleven just around the corner from
here the other day asked me if i smoked
crystals the hair yeah but hey live your
life probably i don't though i watch all
of y'all's videos hot
it seems hallucination
thank you respect mon
so a new poll did you have a poll a
question in mind yeah yeah a question in
mind
um did you guys hit the like button
yes or no
shameless
inside real rejects questions yes
we'll change it soon
okay let's get to the questions though
yeah
no comment yeah
all righty where did we i'm on three
milligrams um
i'm i'm on oh thank you
i'm on three milligrams that tells us we
have been streaming for an hour and a
half i think don't leave a dislike if
you love this show commander keen i see
you none of that
dislikes our engagement but likes are
the best kind of engagement they help
some people get surprised when i say the
whole thing about the how identify as
bisexual when i'm like i did a video
about this like in the very early years
of the channel
is it weird that i assume everyone
identifies as bisexual or is that just
my community there are guys i meet
who are like
like yeah i watch like a lot of dp
porn and uh i haven't actually watched
like porn in a long time good for you um
and uh there's a lot of guys i meet who
who like yeah i'll watch like you know
like multiple guys
like i get you wouldn't do stuff with a
guy but i'm like you can get into like
so like isn't that a form of bisexual
yeah i mean it's just right to the
spectrum right so that would be on that
spectrum i think that's fair isn't it i
feel like it would be yeah i i've always
i've got a whole bit in my stand about
wanting to be bisexual because it's like
another twix bar
and then you got so much more got a
whole other bar i'm just jealous
all right here we go john's pulling it
up we're back in action here so let's do
this let's bring back the display and we
are going to move on to let's give a
round of applause for john hey
running the things he's moderating he's
leading running
writing inspiration from double toasted
life coin and i both had a i had more of
an apprehensive um approach today not
apprehensive more of a cautionary
approach you answered the door in like
full armor gauntlet
are we gonna do this
don't let me see the comments and john's
just making sure i don't read the live
chat man but i've been really i did have
to pull there's another monitor over
there and i had control
pull the chat just the one wrong comment
yeah
the nice thing about this whole thing is
that there's a few people in the chat
for each of us
my comic planet my comic planet my fave
was makari from the badass action scenes
with her fighting icarus with her speed
to the more subtle moments like when she
showed her love for druid with her
infectious smile loved the chemistry
they had i absolutely agree like they
had great chemistry way more than icarus
and cersei yeah i agree
and that was apparently all barry kihon
and her like actually vibin on set he
was like i really want to do you
know i am so in character beautiful
makari i mean he's honoring the homeland
man i appreciate the super chat my
confidence thank you guys thank you to
everyone who's contributed to this
streamlabs and superchats it really
means a lot we do not take that for
granted um we don't live stream a lot so
whenever they do come in like we really
don't take them for granted and thank
you i know this is your hard-earned
dollars and so i appreciate the support
very much so and usually our live
streams have weird playback and they're
often not monetized due to the [ __ ] we
say so let's get back to you guys
apparently boating is a problem you guys
do show here i'm like okay cool thank
you thank you i expect all of this so
just keep it up yeah crashing coyote
super genius who wins icarus vs omni man
versus homeland oh i think koi's the man
answer this one i would vote omni man
okay
i see homelander as being the most
deranged in a negative way where i think
his hostility towards man would cause
him to be overzealous i think homelander
would believe his confidence to a level
that would cause problem whereas uh i
believe icarus and he deep down
somewhere has some bit of seeing himself
as a hero that i think omniman lost so i
think between the three i'm gonna go
omni man
because omniman doesn't perceive himself
as a hero he sees himself as a member of
a species that conquers so he sees
himself as a conqueror and then you've
got uh
omniman i mean then you've got icarus
who deep down somewhere is a hero and
then you've got homelander who i think
his arrogance will be the end of him so
i'm gonna go on to man i'm out of the
three i mean
hey wouldn't eliminate icarus right away
because he doesn't have super speed oh
that's a very good point but he can fly
so they can't hold her um
but there's no speed
who but in icarus like he can fly fast
yeah but there's a reason
he couldn't he couldn't there's a reason
he couldn't talk about it
yeah that's fair omni man could
definitely put up a fight and that's
fair i think omni man just has way more
of a history with like
destroying planets and [ __ ] yeah yeah
he's the super saiyan vegeta of the
three no he would i think he would be
yeah between the three of them he would
totally eliminate them all dustin yoder
in the live chat says we all look tasty
so thank you dustin pandemic jones back
in the supers i have more to say
lol
i think eternals will be appreciated
more when we get deeper in the
multiverse saga and we see how many
doors it has opened i i'm very curious
about what the retroactives will be for
this i mean absolutely like i don't
think there's any discounting that
despite even if you're someone who feels
more like me or more like koi i think
that the the fact is this is the start
of the this is the the introduction let
me take two the precipice
this is
the whole thing about how the world of
the marvel cinematic universe came to be
this is literally genus at the very top
it's it's genesis right there it's their
own bible that they are creating here to
explain how this world and universe came
to be that it's not just a riff on our
earth even though elon musk exists in it
it's not just a riff on our world our
earth you know what i mean so
introducing all that the celestials have
been in like egos there the planet
nowhere there's a lot of about celestial
history that has sort of been spread
throughout celestials and guardians one
my my my concern though is i almost said
concern uh my concern is
are they gonna start acknowledging the
disney plus shows
because the effects of loki i feel like
ty directly just haven't been really
well if you think about that and i see
you all in the live chat because the
live chat has been asking like where did
the celestials figure in in kang's
perfect timeline exactly like there's
there's so much happening and i remember
like avengers end game
that sets up our shows uh of
the the three live action shows we've
gotten so far and it's even going to set
as it even sets up hawkeye but the three
live actions have gone up they so they
had the movies acknowledge it the movie
set up the shows but the it doesn't seem
like they're really acknowledging the
shows so i feel like doctor strange will
be the first one that really does that
this is the beginning yeah that has to
be the first official one to actually do
it because i'm like how are you
introducing the beginning of this world
celestials the whole purpose of earth
was just to give birth to a celestial
and then we got time variants i thought
i'm like are they doing a little too
much right now
to keep up with with crazy world
building because like a lot of this kind
of intersect because they're like
they're going very extreme right now
yeah with the thought process the end
the intellect the headiness as a clone
saga fan i'd rather have them shoot for
an insane like three home run than one
so i hope they land it with but these
are doctors these are all interconnected
totally yeah but i'm saying i'd rather
go big than go small so i'm hoping dr
strange too can do that one thing that
sort of revealed itself to me is i feel
like the spiderman far from home teas
and all that gets you set up for this
thing where it's like everything is
gonna be cause and effect from here on
out and everything is gonna be like the
next progression from this whereas
seeing a lot of what they've been
putting out into phase four thus far
leading up to multiverse and madness it
almost feels like a lot of these things
are sort of disparate
either simultaneous or or sort of tandem
moments that will eventually be
acknowledged when the actual multiversal
madness sure shout out or something but
uh abraham khan i told you i told you
we'd get there the genius the genius of
this movie in my opinion was chloe
zhao's ability to put such complex
themes of morality and the gray areas i
agree with koi top-tier marvel
i want to have a dissertation on
morality mortality and theology more
often i like these conversations you
can't have those a lot of movies marvel
or not you just can't have these
in-depth conversations about what it
means to be alive and at the end of the
day
i think that humans are good as
individuals but bad as a large i like
persons and i'm scared of people i go to
movies to forget being alive koi you
know what a lot of people do but like at
the end of the day i really i worry
about persons and i love people and i
think this movie addresses that in a
really beautiful way oh yeah i mean it
deals with the theme of especially when
cersei's presented with the choice of
what to do it deals with the theme of do
we honor a purpose or do we sacrifice
purpose for love
and that's what life's about yeah i
think i've given up all my dreams
for love
but i think at the end of the day
there's that question like a lot of
people i know that have have been actors
and they found someone they loved and
like they loved the person more than
they loved that dream and like there is
that that moment so and i think it's a
hard thing to address in something like
a superhero film really quick in the
live chat 63 percent of you said you
voted
22 22 percent are just 40
now i love the no comment people because
i know some of you did and some of you
didn't that's an amazing deal this is
good this is going well 500 votes all
right i'm torch is next do you think
that icarus will come back because he is
the main character in the comic book
eternal series also he's my favorite
character
they don't show him die i mean he flies
into the sun
so they don't show him dumb
they don't show him dying i don't know
they don't show him incinerate he could
accept nick's next episode next movie he
might have just charged up on sun juice
he did that for us because he knew we
were watching we wanted it i love them
too but i think the way they handled
them was beautiful icarus flew too close
to the sun such a genius way to use that
metaphor either kyle dube or kele dube i
did appreciate that for sure and i like
that
that him doing that almost makes me go
were you trying to validate sprite
splendid that's what she created about
you yeah it felt like that was like
credibility to that uh uh
dube would love to know each of y'all's
top three eternals me personally i'd say
makari fastos and derwig i would
definitely say um yeah i mean i would
say mccart
okay my personal favorites is i really
like sprite and kingo a lot there's a
there's a technicality side of why but
for the ones i just enjoyed watching the
most it would definitely be makari fasos
and kingo
druid thena makari
uh
okay just just three of uh richard
madden
yeah
it would be like druid mccarry and then
i would have to grapple between like
kingo or or gilgamesh or somebody for
the third one there the third spot is
hard for me to pick but druid and makari
are definitely my two faves ten great
cast members absolutely and and despite
whatever in the scripting you know
despite whatever i agree with about uh
with greg or with koi on about the
scripting i feel like across the board i
thought the cast really showed up even
richard madden i thought he showed up
regardless of what they gave him to
burke don't blink
yes
dc big oh so yeah
was i the only one crashing no no i was
just trying not to blink coy you should
have stopped at duncan all right was i
the only one getting all-star superman
vibes what was dunking clothes it was a
hollywood boulevard marathon that's why
it took so long to get here that was
literally a marathon on the street it's
like right yeah it was a struggle i
literally sat in my car for two hours to
leave thank you
uh
yeah was i the only one getting all-star
superman vibes from the third act with
icarus
yes
it's over i was waiting for you the
first person to point that out you know
right in america all star superman is
this great commentary on like what we've
become as a nation and it's obviously
inspired omniman and a lot of the other
characters we've introduced but i do
believe uh that is the basis for a lot
of these characters that people feel
like icarus is based off of and ulster
superman is a fantastic run everyone
check out from grant morrison so yes i
got that vibe yes i appreciate you
noticing hells yeah lit fuse underscore
gd get ready koi because this is for koi
going off go off coy
well he's he's already done it i think
he's calmed down a couple times boy's
gonna go off again don't worry
more of the children of loki and they've
settled i could feel more coy's energy
like he's a little more subdued now guys
got the anger out right yeah it's pretty
good oh it's a little different he sat
here for two hours i've been sitting
here for almost two hours i just got out
of the road for two hours to come here
and now sit here for another two hours i
got my hyphy out yeah two hours back and
then a two hour nap and then a two-hour
dream
aaron james i liked it a lot but it was
very long had one too many characters
and not enough action we'll watch it
again on disney plus here's the other
side some people want more actions
that's why there was the long scenes
that we said we would have cut so it's
different structured than folks i think
it's just really the placement of the
action sometimes it could especially
when you the thing is when you think
about pacing and tone
if you
okay i don't uh if if
or pacing tone and structure despite
your guys's sarcasm
those things are important
there's a big difference for me between
john wick one and john wick two and
that's because
a big part in setting the stage john
wick one does not have action until
breaking act two when they come to his
house so you're setting the tone and the
mood in the states you're not having
this expectation of a lot of action or
whatever so when you get your first
action scene it's very rewarding and
impactful and i think what this movie
kind of goes wrong with that regard of
what sets people up to want more action
is the fact that it starts off with a
with a big action scene
right at the top
and i think that's why that expectation
is set so you kind of feel like you need
a little bit more action from time like
at least like one because i think it's
around the
after the forest fight it's like a lot
of no action for a while you know it's
just a lot of just talking which i don't
mind personally but i think action
creates a certain type of stimuli and
then you're not getting that stimuli uh
because you're now it's just like
settling watching and expectations of
mcu definitely come into that yeah it's
oh a thousand percent so like i i don't
uh begrudge people when they feel that
way of
wanting more action and i think a part
of that comes from mcu standards and uh
or expectation and also the fact that
this movie starts off with a big action
scene yeah and i think the first act
action scene has become a tradition in
the mcu that the movie isn't the
traditional mcu film yeah
commander keenan in the chat wants to
know if this is as good a film as
martyrs uh they're very similar and you
should watch them back to back john
mcgoon to hear makari scream in her real
voice when icarus tried to kill druid
was so visceral it made me cry you know
what i i absolutely love that especially
to have a deaf actress you know
vocalize or whatever uh and i love that
across the board and i i saw a brief
little clippit of an interview with
brian tyree henry where he was like okay
they gave me the roll i was like all
right sweet you want me to work out how
much weight you want me to lose and they
were like no no no we want you as you
are they said gain weight and get
blocker gateway
but i i really loved that about them
where i was like yeah they assembled
this you know multicultural cast from
all over the world
or at least with roots from all over the
world and let them just bring their
accents and bring themselves and i
thought that was really wonderful also
and this is again gonna piss off the
right people uh i really enjoyed the
fact that it didn't feel like they
plucked people to be the stereotypes of
the nationality that american audiences
see them as we didn't have the cliches
in any of these races but we did have
different races represented while also
like people complaining it's so woke we
have four of the 11 leads are [ __ ]
white the whitest of whites an irishman
a scot a brit and a [ __ ] angelina
jolie so like out of that we have other
races represented but people still
complaining that it's woke but at the
end of the day if your 10 closest
friends are all of the same town as you
you probably don't know a lot of [ __ ]
like if everyone's from your same
hometown you probably just know how good
the wendy's [ __ ] fries are so i
really like that at the end of the day
10 different cultures is how an alien
race would have people interpret the
world you wouldn't have someone from the
same nation represented 10 times you
wouldn't have someone of the same
religion or sexuality because that
wouldn't blend into the world and this
is a movie that feels like it's made for
the world not feel like it's made for
america if you want to watch a movie
that feel like it made for america watch
like 70s [ __ ] action movies with all
the whites there's so much to this and
so much advancement of it that i hope
this is what phase four five and beyond
are because i don't want to just see the
avengers be six white dudes again
yeah they should hear my car's screaming
a real voice when nicoras tried to kill
drug that was what i was talking about
so visceral
you mentioned fastos he mentioned him
getting to be his own body weight and be
you know what
you know what greg koi this is why i
bring you here to do that
dark jedi
also if you have ten friends and one of
them is gay you're statistically just
hiding to other friends i'm just saying
like poor mike hasn't come out yet but
he will mike will come out and he's
going to tell you in an inopportune
moment and so will karen
i absolutely love koi saying what many
of us want to say but can't articulate
hashtag koi rant you do have a way
articulating and pulling those words
together and you you perhaps more than
anyone i've ever met can pull out
like
articulate arguments in like a really
mad cap like oh my god i am so tense
watching you form this sentence but here
it comes and it's got like 12 syllable
words in it damn that's my secret cap
i'm always [ __ ] angry so all of that
bottled rage just comes out at [ __ ] and
you guys aren't all guns but the ones
that are upset receive the rage because
they know what's at them boom that's why
i appreciate the super chats guys
absolutely because we can't monetize
that word
the doomer says imagine youtube's like
maybe okay no we're not gonna listen 20
minutes
says eternal set the bar for speedster
scenes and superhero movies going
forward and the dumeris wants to imagine
paperboy from atlanta is fastas and i i
just flashed to the episode of of him
lost in the woods and uh yeah it's good
i want it
matrixter no no katherine dawson foy
catherine dawson foy good catch g didn't
like druid left makari for thousands of
years and then when they all were back
together they were lovey-dovey okay
that's my question about druik this is a
question before i turn it into a
criticism i want to ask
see see you can do that guys
you can go can you let me go with
another one
druid he turns the people uh what what
what was that part of history again i
forget specifically
are they in babylonia when there was a
baby when he first started oh the masses
when he goes down
yeah that was babylon which is a
beautiful shot so
the last
seven thousand years he's only been
there no
he's had other cultures in the woods he
says like he this is where we first met
this is where i last saw you guys when
when the eternal show up so when he said
that i was like oh has he only been
helping out these people
as the entire time as much as i i don't
think it's good practice necessarily to
look at a movie and go ah you can fill
in the blank when the blank is like
thousands of years i just assumed like
oh maybe he left went elsewhere came
back here maybe this is just home base
for well he knew kingo was a movie star
so he's got to have some type of yeah
outside of here before yeah i guess i
have the same response of like i assume
he left and came back like that was his
hub but like you don't stay somewhere
seven thousand years fair enough he
loves the woods he's just that much of a
home body matrix stark just gives a flat
100 i appreciate the support we are
keeping it 100. brendan
christian uh kristiniak i hope i'm
saying that right my only problem was
crow near the end i forgot about him and
was like oh yeah then followed by oh now
he's dead i guess
he was real underused i feel
yeah for some reason they because they
the first time i watched crow in the
movie when he first turns human yeah
kind of like felt like an old almost an
ultron james spader moment at that time
i was like oh they're do what no they're
doing stuff with them and i was so like
kind of impressed that they were doing
that maybe there's a reason that cast
bill skarsgard who i didn't know was in
the city so so i liked it more uh quite
a bit the first time i watched it but
the second time around i really did feel
like he
it becomes really underused which i know
we've already kind of touched on it's
the start of an amazing of a good idea
that doesn't get to be explored and
honestly on imax the effects of the
deviants stand out way like they didn't
bother me the first time i watched it
but on imax because of that crystal
clear imax quality yeah i was like oh
the effects really stand out i think
it's because it was shot on film and
most smart movies are shot digitally but
they use imacs that's lovely yeah but i
think i think the depth of the other
scenes the texture of film true is going
to look different when you add a digital
to on top of the film stuff yeah oh
especially because they shoot a lot on
actual location yeah as opposed to green
screen which is digital yeah so so you
have a lot more manipulation and shadow
it's like in the 90s when you use the
black line around things like most
marvel films aren't shot like actually
blank but then they had to compensate
for like let's darken the [ __ ] out of
the forest fight itself
because
and and honestly unlike the the first
time we watched the turtles i couldn't
tell what was going on in that forest
fight but the second time on imax i was
like okay it's a tight it's a little
brighter but we addressed the crow thing
and i and i think it's all it's going to
be the interpretation of the viewer i
got a lot out of it that greg didn't
even have that experience of but i think
it's all choose your own goosebumps guys
we fall behind on our yeah don't don't
worry dark jedi knight you're you're
ahead of you're
coming up we're trying to rush torres we
watch the [ __ ] out of ted lasso it's
exemplary yeah that's pretty i think
i haven't seen an episode all right
green lantern i don't want to play 4.99
no uh yeah green lantern and brightest
day and darkest night hey coy especially
but greg and john as well what was your
take on the celestials hey koi is
special
hey koi i guess greg
while they're here uh as well what was
your take on the celestials and their
overall presence in the film i feel like
we've touched on this but koi i'm sure
you're the especially i mean i was i was
called out i feel like i need to i
enjoyed the fact that i read these
characters as a kid one of my first
introductions to this concept of
character was the amalgam universe when
we first meet the living tribunal and
it's this overwhelming deity in space
that just controls so much of reality i
didn't think i would feel that in a
movie i thought it was one of those
things that would live better in the
comic books because your imagination
takes control i loved that i was
watching a film and i was able to go
like oh [ __ ] about a character that i
didn't think would translate so i
enjoyed the celestials i want to see
more of that i think guardians 3 and
forward are gonna have a lot more cosmic
stuff and i
generally which is ironic considering
how i live my life i enjoy
really heady stuff and i enjoy uh in
life as koi i enjoy drug culture and
reading and existential crises and
thinking about the world in my comics i
don't enjoy the cosmic stuff as much as
i enjoy the underdog stuff like i like
spider-man and x-men to stay on earth
but then in life i'm like what if i'm a
cosmonaut so it's interesting now that
these worlds are blending because these
are characters that i read that i was
like
but now that they're in movies i'm like
oh yeah and it's this weird zeitgeist
shift for me kind of like watching the
matrix and it it's i do appreciate the
effectiveness of it because a lot of the
time the scale does not quite read in
like a pacific rim manner yes
like guillermo del toro's pacific rim
specifically or
i would even say uh the first godzilla
the the gareth who was his name evans
edwards
edwards okay council get that confusion
gareth edwards uh his version that
captured the scale of godzilla this one
i thought really does that and for it to
be this deep into the films where you
get a lot of like crazy [ __ ] and like
even even sound design where it was like
yeah so i i think uh i think it's really
cool that to this day they
uh even at this point they can have that
level of effectiveness
with that big cgi
monster or whatever like
shitty word you want to apply to it but
yeah but like big cgi creature yeah
absolutely more celestials absolutely
i'll keep it quick i absolutely want to
see more of the celestials and i love
anything that's like huge and scopic
like that and and i love
that the pitch of this or at least you
know one one thing you could draw i
don't know if this was actually what she
said but that whole thing of like let's
do prometheus from the engineers pov and
uh i thought the celestials added nicely
to that whole thing absolutely um to me
one of the things i liked most about the
film was feeling small i liked that as a
human being i felt like i was an ant and
i think the celestials made that a very
very appropriately visual thing
stephanie m gendro i know her in the
live chat uh is glad we're still live
because she's at work and it got so busy
at amc with stephanie stop saying mommy
photos
yeah
i i've said how funny you should say
that because commander keen wants to
know if thanos is naked in this movie
and a few people have chimed in that he
was yeah oh yeah naked as hell with two
nuts well there's that scene where
ant-man does the thing that a lot of
people theorize but end in game but he
does it as a kinky choice he became he
was like
yeah it's like you think he's going to
take him out but then thanos is all
about it yeah he asked for that he's
like
crazy i am inevitable
[Laughter]
corey ross now you got to monetize
corey ross
thanks for everybody too who answered
our our poll about the likes i hope
you've left a like since then and check
out the new polls if you want to see it
but tony um
tony odajimi in the chat did say
something that i do want to point out
that there's an art that i think
christopher nolan in particular has
mastered if you watch this on imax
you'll see the aspect ratio change and
um nolan is easily the one who has
mastered knowing like i think he maps
that out in his like beforehand of
for the edits
yeah
and especially within the same scene i
don't feel chloe zhao had a great handle
on it and she did point out that it was
kind of jarring and the way the aspect
ratio kept changing and i imagine if you
watch this on a real imax like we
watched a kind of a shittier imax
but our real i'm actually like like a
universal one where it's like you walk
in and the screen feels like you're
looking upon a celestial like those kind
of screens
where the aspect ratio you'll you'll see
it's like oh the film's here then it's
here then it's here this year
yeah and it happens a lot in the same
scene where it's
but on a real imax it would be jarring
and and i think uh it was interesting
there's some moments she chose to shoot
with imax or i'm like why'd you choose
to shoot this scene with imax backdrop
which is so nice we gotta accentuate
that production
they're not even it's just a simple
talking moment yeah they're at a cafe
erica in the chat says more coy guys
which i always love to hear
let's go over here
corey ross
okay uh chloe was able to tell us uh
the turn in the opening shot and made
omash the most important sci-fi films of
all time the matrix star trek 3 beyond
uh 2001 a space odyssey through the lens
of the mcu of course this was going to
be divisive
wait you're saying because of that it
would be divided why would that make it
divisive just just an homage shot to the
emotional i think he's saying those kind
of films are not in the usual pantheon
of mcu so accomplishing that i think
was 2001 space odyssey considered
divisive when it first came out putting
space odyssey in the mcu pantheon i'm
saying like incorporating that kind of
filmography into the mcu i think that's
what he's saying is like trying that
kind of filmmaking in this world okay
yeah i gotcha i think i don't feel like
it goes that hard though
it goes pretty hard for being different
from the mcu for being different but i'm
saying in terms of going hard into like
the stanley cup
it's certainly not i think definitely
goes more kubrick but i'd say this is
closer to doon than iron man
sure so therefore i would say it's more
in that direction yeah yeah i would say
that i'd say this is a seven out of ten
in the on the doom i mean it's one of
the more tangible mcu moves
really quick uh yeah i mean that's what
john and i talked about on on when we
talked about the ron tomato score that
we don't think the comparison to thor
the dark world is fair just because
you're looking at a number when i'm like
i wouldn't even compare this to the dark
world they're two vastly different films
yeah i would i wouldn't compare this so
to say like it's worse than thor the
dark world like hey that's subjective b
um uh objectively speaking they're very
different and i don't think they should
be com
i don't think those are the one-to-one
comparisons you want to make jb
bonifacio an australian podcast just
interviewed salma hayek who says that
she had signed up for multiple film
deals and was surprised that they killed
her off in the first 20 minutes of the
movie
could this mean that eternal 2 is
supposed to be about eros leading them
to the world forge since she's coming
back
oh fascinating why would she reveal that
uh one i will say that selma hack might
not be as used to the feige secrecy as
as other like i i know when new big
movie stars come on they're so used to
being like and here's the ending of my
movie like
oh no this is the new world of internet
i do feel like some hayak is like a
movie star from the era right before the
mcu that might not be used for
flashbacks exactly what my point was
going to be is that you have to when you
sign on the mcu to sign on for like five
movies like i think that's part of the
conversation it's not the nine film
deals that it was in phase one but i do
think there's at least the option to
renew your contract so as exciting as
this is it doesn't say what i think at
another studio would say and i would
love to see more eternals with her but i
don't think that's as finite as we would
hope considering the box office and the
uh i mean not the box office
thank you jb isaac mechler i thought the
first third was kind of uninteresting
but the last two thirds maybe really
like this movie also i barely learned
about pip and eras a week ago so it was
cool to see them at the very end
i feel like the surprise it is like
their big the big takeaway is pip and
arrows more so than the fact that we got
blade in there this is a lot of people a
lot of people didn't knows blade and i
was like so obviously
most people aren't going to know it's
blade and irish ali's voice is so unique
okay i think the masses are not going to
reckon i think hunger games a lot there
are people at the perimeter everyone saw
him there there were people at the
premiere who thought was that sam
jackson i heard that go around a lot
basically that everyone has a specific
ear for black voices
your voice racist you don't see color
but you hear it
and but we were i mean we were very i i
would say his voice is more similar to
jeffrey wright than it is to sam jackson
again i'm biased um but mercer but the
thing is i feel like most people won't
know and i think a lot of people
actually i love learning that it was
blade
i think a lot of people are disappointed
though i think there is a big camp that
is disappointed that their first
introduction to blade is just some
off-screen voice it makes it more
ominous ready to die [ __ ] it's
like it's it's more blade to be in the
shadows like blade i love what wesley
snipes did for that's a great point like
that is a great [ __ ] point like blade
is an incredible character in the film
universe
you you've completely eliminated any
citizens
i'm like [ __ ] you're absolutely right
they're introducing a new blade what
better way to introduce blade than more
like he is in the comics which is a
character from the shadows you introduce
a supernatural element like the ebony
blade you do it through blade it's the
ebony blade with blade it's so much more
comicy i think it's appropriate hells
yeah the comic planet is back up in here
uh part one of two part one and two eric
v said for icarus to assume fastest made
his table out of vibranium showed that
other vibranium tech might have been
aided by fastos i love that i mean i
believe that that was the implication
was that pretty much all the technology
was it was aided by fastest i mean he
came up with the engine and the freaking
um
and the plow
homeboy gave us the plow and also that
fastness may have been the source that
provided howard stark with vibranium for
cap shield wow did you guys catch that
uh i am now
i hadn't thought that far but it
absolutely makes sense that's a very
good point i i had missed that i've only
seen this at once but that is i'm gonna
look for that now thank you um
vibranium for the original shield coming
from the eternals gives them that like
rooted in the mcu thing that they're
looking for because they they did not ex
i mean i think one way to look about
look about it then is because
howard stark got the vibranium cap
shield they don't really explain how he
got the vibranium but then you do see
fastos work with the with the bomb
um
my god why am i blanking on what was
that called the atomic bomb the atomic
bomb
our biggest bomb is the species
the atomic bomb and that must have been
a little bit after the events with
howard stark and captain america right
yeah look at the timeline and that might
have made him go i'm not going to help
out with the with the government anymore
right which i've always loved about
winter okay that like perspective shift
uh but yeah but i'm saying that uh that
would make that would line up with the
timeline he probably implemented
something with howard stark and
vibranium but didn't help out with uh
yeah i liked that a lot what i noticed
the second time around was like wait a
minute kinko's talking about thor so
thor must know about the it's like they
must know about the eternals and they're
like what's their relation asgardians or
the with the i think they accept that
they can't intervene because in the
beginning remember um odin didn't want
them to intervene either but thor being
arrogant did yeah odin very specifically
said like no don't [ __ ] with midgard so
i think it's accepted that asgardians
and eternals are both not supposed to
[ __ ] with midgard but thor being
arrogant and loving jane does what if
season two the eternals just keep
intervening that's the whole thing
ever follow those rules
all of it spider-man crushes smile no
spider-man
good tony stark never built that cave
with the scraps still in the foot in the
desert william jones john you got to
read that super chat my friends for you
yes
william jones this super chat is for
john
protect john
protect me it's up to you
protect you you are the one you think
you've got to feel protected
i mean you know as long as you guys are
cool
with each other
the more you guys you know get hated the
more worried i become because you know
being in the middle ground at some point
i'm going to be called to decide
this is 28 proof
sure so it's 13. no it's it's 13.5
percent so 27 proof i've mailed the [ __ ]
out because i've had a lot of children
of loki there you go
william jones i feel very very loved
right now though i think this is the
first super chat directly directed at me
so that that makes my day john magoon
i think this movie with its mixed
reviews will become a cult classic i
loved it it's way too big to become way
too mainstream
it's from the biggest franchise from the
biggest studio in the biggest country on
earth
if anything you would like i wouldn't
call bvs a cult classic because i think
bvs is a film that has actually grown
with a lot more appreciation over time
especially after its ultimate edition
and um like i know a lot of people still
hate that movie but a lot of people i
think have really come around on it and
zack snyder's vision he saw how big zack
snyder's justice league was so but i
wouldn't call that a cult film
and uh i think this movie stands that
though i would i would liken it more to
that is that if anything the
appreciation for this is probably just
going to get bigger i think it'll grow
and i think a beloved audience will be
vocal exactly that that's what i would
like in him more too but i wouldn't call
it a cult classic and on the heels of
that our most recent poll absolutely
wants to see an eternal sequel eight
percent of you said nah and eighteen
percent want to see the characters
brought back some places edibles yeah
that is exactly the opposite of my
initial thought that's so it makes me so
happy that people love this movie that
gives me so much hope bring on the seek
josh martin hey if anything
i was very vocal
on twitter
weeks ago of saying like i don't get why
people think this is going to be so
divisive with audiences
i was saying i don't i don't think it's
going to be that divisive with audiences
i really feel like most people are going
to really like this movie i was very
very apparent about that but the critics
score surprised the [ __ ] out of him yeah
and i was gonna be honest about that
that was like whoa i did not expect that
um i thought there'd be a lot more film
snobs out there but that that one really
surprised me but the audience i'm not
surprised by that at all i'm so happy to
be wrong yeah read some alan watts he'll
dig it josh martin hey guys really enjoy
all y'all's content for me i really
enjoyed this movie that said i am with
coy and really don't get the criticism
is this because it's not a traditional
mcu movie [ __ ] it after three hours i'm
just going to say yes yes
that's why 100 that's why i feel that
way i think art is subjective and i get
why people don't like it no it's just
koi space facts it's just it's
not a traditional entrepreneur where was
robert downey jr and uh there's only
i've been looking there's a little
esoteric crowd of people who really get
this you can take every movie you've
ever seen and go what is this movie
trying to do and how successfully is it
achieving it and there you are
thought process
yes david that's what annoyed me the
most and some of the comments of of like
gray just doesn't get after like an
hour-long talk with you where we [ __ ]
broke it yeah like we literally deep
dive and i'm like after apollo i'm like
[ __ ] it sure why not yeah
likewise it's that simple it's that
simple
someone's saying i didn't get it when i
was like here's me spelling out what i
received like there's no pleasing people
david blown wants to know do you feel
this will be essential given how
polarized the reactions are in effect uh
marvel makes the film's events more
relevant a la thor too dude [ __ ] thor
two's events are very important yeah big
part of end game i think every movie is
so essential and i do think they're
going to be leaning on this for the
cosmic elements going the only one that
fights for essentialness is the
incredible hulk that's the only and iron
man 2
yeah every so often you're like remember
sam rockwell was here yeah i want more
same rockwell like there's i think that
like when we have armor wars it's just
going to be him with his like tan yeah
remember i was in the universe but i
really think uh i think that no this one
was absolutely essential i think feige
has really been setting the ground for
that before two and then the lead up to
this release i want more like this this
is gonna change everything well it's a
fabric of the of the
cinematic universe movie so yeah i feel
like it's significant regardless
yeah david cooley does hey this is a
good koi question i feel like does
galactus kill celestials when eating
planets what i think is going to happen
is when we bring in the fantastic four
there's going to be an element of cosmic
wonder there's going to be an element of
how powerful are these characters of the
cosmic wonder of how powerful these
character characters are in general and
i think galactus might end up fighting a
celestial to show his strength so i
think that when we're meeting these
entities we're going to have to
differentiate our power structures blow
the smoke in your face while you're
talking bring it i'm gonna guess
but i do think galactus is going to have
to fight something that is of a
celestial scope in order to show
everyday audiences who this character is
because so far we've only had galactus
as a concept or a [ __ ] space cloud
neither of those things are really
intimidating so i think the best way to
do it is bring him into the mcu through
this tet attack with a celestial and i
love that question
seon ayatmaru
i like the movie quite a bit i love the
sense of scale with the celestials makes
me hyped for galactus
heck yeah man galactus is going to be
scary af who should play galactus
comment in the chat michael shannon uh
sure really i just love him that's a
great thing about that big that scope
that intimidating
gravitas i will eat all of you
i will eat him i will
give me that mikey
with the headpiece just as michael chan
like don't even make it a weird shot
just him in that costume go google
michael shannon in the movie grand theft
parsons and he is the li he's the
spitting image of bo burnham in the
inside special oh he's got the beard and
the long hair and i'm like that's
michael shannon but i just see bow
burning also his reading the the
cheerleaders thing on funny or die
absolutely he's a god ethan holgate
first thing i saw barry cogan
in what
keown you sure all right first thing i
saw barry keown in was an irish show
called love hate he was only in one
season he's come a long way since then
he's huge now in marvel uh he's huge now
i mean i feel like two he had that a24
boost where he was in like half their
movies for a while and dunkirk and
dunkirk and now he's just yeah yeah he's
he's a he's a giant irish movie star
which makes me happy because in this he
got to be actually irish which is very
true but is he in belfast
god i hope sounds like the avengers end
game of irish
assemble the irishman stuff
william joe maybe that's why there
weren't enough actual irish people in
the irish that's why you hate it i mean
you cast de niro noted italian you put
them in the irishmen what do you want
from that's like southie and north end
trying to be one town it's not one town
they're two you don't go to southie to
get your cannolis you don't go to the
north end to get your beer
william jones i thought ajac only
decided to fight the emergence after the
avengers brought back half the
population of the universe she realized
that this planet shouldn't be destroyed
she still had plenty of time
i mean the blip happened a little while
later
you didn't have to wait until a few days
and i still think i'm fighting
specifically it icarus was not a wise
choice
yes i feel like you would have known
that it's icarus is not though can you
refresh that yes sir too so all right
we're going to refresh this and turn off
the yeah we should probably do that
because we've been here for a while hour
and a half
two wait no two and a half in a couple
hours whoa here we go we went live at 11
45. so yeah it's been a little bit of
time
but i want to make sure we get all the
all the chats done
generosity here we appreciate it even
maybe get a new poll
doing okay koi i'm just making sure my
mom texts me i want to see if she's
relating to this nobody she was just
saying she sent me cat photos there you
go the chat wants to know who is
stronger between phil coulson and icarus
man coulson inspired
all right guys
thank you
to everyone who has submitted today we
are turning off the super chats for
right now officially so uh
you know
the thought is what counts
alrighty let's jump back in where are we
at let's find out
we made enough money to pick william
jones
no my rate 5k
i'm out of here she realized the plan
shouldn't be destroyed william jones all
right we're back and uh let's do also
just a little quick refresher on the
stream can i acknowledge i'm gonna
acknowledge chat it's gonna happen i
know de niro has irish blood in him too
but he plays italian mafioso so it just
felt like sacrilege they shouldn't have
done with that movie they shouldn't have
changed his eye color it was so many
weird choices
yeah i call her especially i was like
this is [ __ ] also the same where they
did the flashback where he's like 20 but
he moves like a seven-year-old man i was
like this is just painful
yeah like let's hear her have some
integrity like have a body double for
that one scene
um
i don't think the irishman's perfect but
i like it a lot i i'm glad it has an
audience
ghostly arranger we're not ending just
yet but we are ending we're gonna answer
these questions a little bit quick
though just because we take too much
time here charles harkins so icarus
don't have to read the whole question
yeah sure next one
all right icarus is my first time being
connected to a marvel character and the
heel turn happened but i think he and
sprite will team up in the next why will
they team up sprite's a human now sprite
got her wish yeah she's gonna grow up
she's gonna be an adult she's gonna die
but i don't regret it i did think the
choice though with kingo i like the
choice that kinga was like i'm not gonna
harmony you due to my beliefs i'm just
gonna i'm gonna go i'm out i think this
but when they go back to kingo
i thought it was kind of weird how kingo
seemed to have like no
reaction to the fact that of what they
ended up going through with doing yeah
he was like i guess i was neutral enough
to just be here yeah he's just like so
neutral towards the whole thing and i
thought it was a little bit weird that
there wasn't even a bit of like a
knowledgeable indulgence towards the
fact that they didn't go through with
the way he thought things should have
gone down yeah one of my three negatives
is it's for me it's the relationship
with them to the kingo thing and for me
it was um i forgot my third because i
have a lot of beer but i like that they
had their um that they ended up having
you see that's why i don't smoke weed or
drink
as i get the crash two hours
yeah so i don't do that um
so yeah but i but uh no i think it was
great though when sprite does go with
kingo in the end because they do have
that set up on the plane of like i
thought we were friends you could you
could feel the history of tension that
they had due to the fact that they went
their separate ways i agree so yeah
absolutely ryan knew some gavin knew
some son that's right now that eternals
is out and there was rumors of x-men
reference from eternals do you think do
you still think eternals is responsible
for x-men in the mcu future that's a
very high probability but i think we're
going to need some multiverse [ __ ]
really and uh i don't want to go into
the leaks i do feel like multiverse i do
think multiverse is where x-men come in
i think it's less eternals than ever
especially with how the movie played out
i do think
it would have been an option to plant an
ex-gene conversation but since they
really didn't i do think it's going to
be a fully formed
x gene elsewhere and i do think doctor
strange is going to be that answer
you're looking for very true i i believe
that full heartedly that the answer for
x-men is going to come in the hands of
doctor schreider that movie has to be
seven movies i fully fully believe it
good luck dark jedi knight i honestly
don't understand why this movie got a
lower score than thor two this movie
makes you see how small you are in
comparison with the universe uh they're
very different movies and they're gonna
have very different responses thor at
least for the most part um still adheres
to
familiar mcu formula yeah where this
doesn't so you're just likely and thor
two doesn't even have a terrible
audience score no it's got a b plus
which is not fair uh cinema score and a
75 audience score so it's still fresh
all around with the audiences despite
the kind of talk surrounding that movie
um but that's i think that's a big
reason why it's because thor at least is
like it's got the action and the weird
jokes and the [ __ ] familiar structure
and and we like chris hemsworth and adam
portman yeah exactly
uncomfortable not the same comparison
they're they're very one and also too
you also shouldn't compare because one's
a sequel and right and this one is a
first installment and an introduction of
ten characters shouldn't be compared to
a sequel of character that's beloved
exactly 100
thanks to sean mclaughlin in the chat my
scottish accent really did inspire all
of this uh
pretty fly for a philippines
oh pinoy pride in the house i enjoyed
the thought provoking eternals if this
is an elseworld jl movie i'll take it
question if thanos is part deviant why
didn't the help why did they help the
avengers fight him
i think they explained it through the he
has to be full deviance it has to be a
direct directive it needs to be um
it needs to cause the conflict and
arguably the conflict from thanos is the
direct reason for the ability for the
celestial to emerge faster the the
ability of everyone to come back at once
remember half the population came back
and that was the energy surge that
allowed the celestial to be born sooner
which is another of the reasons i felt
samahaike didn't fight sooner was
because it was the immediate spike of
the thanos return like the snap coming
everyone back i think they thought that
celestial wouldn't be born for another
like 5 000 years but it was the
re-emergence of half the population so
you'd want that to happen yeah so
therefore the thanos thing was a win for
the celestials see i think uh i think
eric vassar heard him bring up a theory
about how since arrows has one of those
celestial
little marbles
vacation beacon thing that thanos
probably had some type of connection
with the celestial too and maybe his
actions were a thing going against the
celestials it could be i'm curious if
they addressed that because it'd be fun
to see like young thanos and [ __ ] yeah
chad wants to know goodbye harry styles
chash wants to know who would win in
gilgamesh versus a hulk fight and uh
giovanni bereggio loves coy's energy
thanks giovanni i think gilgamesh uh
would put up a solid fight and i like
your deadpool icon mara kagan
maybe no mara aka gone there it is we'll
see it literally just got out of the
cinema from eternals harry styles got me
laughing so hard but with the czech
voice over i didn't recognize the voice
in the second post credit scene yeah i
mean that's fair it's more fair than a
lot of people not recognizing them i
would love to experience a dub version
of one of these movies one day
um i saw avengers age of ultron in south
africa and i saw it in english but
everyone talking about the movie had
like eight different accents so i was
just sitting in the theater like
absorbing energy
it was one of the coolest things to just
hear excitement in every language oh
cool it was awesome shuvo raman
controversial eternal's best marvel
movie this year black widow was crap and
shang chi was good
i liked all three but this is my
favorite of the three i thought shang
chi uh
was better than black widow but i
enjoyed black
i
widow
rank them
yeah
eternals black widow yeah me too all
right but i would put one division above
all them i put loki above all of them
one division and loki i constantly go
back and forth it's like how i am with
terminator 2 and matrix which was
followed by a captain and winter soldier
then way down here that said the moment
with cap and the shield in the in the
center is one of my favorite moments in
mcu history like the the actual like
police brutality scene is up there for
the whole mcu we don't talk about falcon
when we're sold enough dude we don't
that's absolutely in fairness i forgot
that that's in that [ __ ] moment dude
i'm just saying a black falcon man
robbie brown what do you guys think will
be the eternal's first appearance in a
separate marvel film series
captain marvel 2.
uh
multiverse of men i think i think i
think my favorite matters will get one
internal i think we'll see an eternal
title together oh you know there are
things that gemma chan does that are a
little bit reflective of what doctor
strange has done in the past yeah uh
some druid i could see blended in with
that world god you know you really you
and your irish
frankly i think druid brings in the
x-men he's going to be like hey i like
that guy's accent banshee you come with
me banshee first irishman it's all canon
does not think the eternals will be
responsible for introducing x-men i
don't think so either except
that's good
that's good banshee and siren noted
irish people through true but i'm happy
that 13 of you accept x-men origins as
canon the doomer
greg is bi
koi is crack positive
john what's your big reveal i'm a
professional dominatrix
okay i'm gonna say i'm not crack
negative i'm not crack positive i just
don't judge people for whatever they got
going on there's a big difference not
encouraging crack i'm saying like
whatever your fancy as long as you're
not hurting others i support you crack
isn't whack crack is nuanced i'm just if
you got a thing i'm not gonna judge it
that's all i think and that might be bi
but i'm also extremely homophobic yes i
mean we've heard
actually he was talking about himself
he's like this other guy was talking to
him
with my other side
i was hitting on this guy and he was
into me and i was like
bro what's up i'm not gonna go that way
you're hitting on me we're in west
hollywood so i'm doing my boy now
doesn't buy me split personality i
thought i'm not gonna that's what i
thought it meant i'm not gonna follow
any of this
hey guys flicking real nine out of ten
from jackal jesse swift hey
fellow quirky mercy see you as
spectacular
i will miss it i'm skipping it i don't
care i i say hello down the street i
recorded an episode on the christian
harlot show and he didn't turn the sound
on that's fair if you're i mean that's
that's that's drove a very long way and
yeah you're watching
the whole three hours
to have a great conversation an hour and
a half and uh now i want nothing to do
with harloff he's a horrible
horrible
horrible joker
first i'm just sitting here like i'm not
going to say shout out sally i'm so bad
in a moment right now i really don't
care my toilet spoiler review of the big
thing drops tomorrow with christian
harloff and uh
it just makes me laugh that he feels so
bad about it because i'm like you don't
have to feel that
i literally called greg like dude i'm so
sorry that happened to you so i just
messed with it because it just makes me
it works it works
no energy i know against him i just feel
bad for everything i just keep doing it
because of that
jesse
shouts out to you i still feel terrible
for not being as supportive of a faction
mate as i should see him in december he
is such an exactly such a lovely guy we
got a busy schedule billy december 4th
it's hard to schedule anything that's
not in this room uh william jones how
much do you think covid and the delayed
movie schedule impacted the disney plus
and movie tie-ins a lot
but maybe not as much as i don't think
it affected the tie-ins of course the
schedule but i don't think affected
tie-ins i don't think they were like uh
we can't tie it in anymore oh yeah
that's fair because the release schedule
is getting [ __ ] up yeah i do think it
affected the next chunk more than this
chunk i do think doctor strange was
affected strongly which caused a
cascading domino effect of pushes i
think doctor strange and their so marvel
films like 80 to 90 percent of their
movie and then they do additional
photography of 10 to 20 of each movie
the additional photography as well as
the end of their photography and a
number of films was shifted because of
kovid i think that caused a six month
push in doctors train multiverse of
madness which then caused a cascading
effect for the rest of phase four so i
think everything after this was much
more affected by covid than everything
up to this point
terrible answer clearly i know i just um
where's belladonna bella i messaged you
on twitter uh to say thank you for all
the feedback and yet i don't see
anything here in the chat belladonna
1363. i appreciate your moment chad sam
thank you for the bella
i've been very vocal about um your
support for this movie even before you
even got to see it and i i i admire
your connectivity to the material
at hand
moving on motorola no question just
commenting coy
you know there's too much love for koi
in this in these super chats
only greg and john connor
now that we cut off the super chats
they're making a direction about less
coy it was cool to see you do your thing
at the nerdist event thursday night guys
i got to introduce eternals to the world
the first public screening at the el
capitan disney's own theater i got to
introduce and host and present eternals
which i did not find out i was doing
until after i started reviewing it so
there was some kickback from you'll be
like oh you only loved it because
actually i loved it comma got to present
it and uh it's really cool it's one of
my one of my great honors anytime i get
to produce and present one of these
movies um from the side of fandom it
makes me realize how far i've come from
reading comics and not having friends
that read comics and like being at a
comic store by myself i literally at 14
was sorting comics for like two dollars
an hour for fun and now i get to be on
the biggest stage in the world
presenting these movies for marvel and
it is an honor and i appreciate each and
every one of you supporting me allowing
that to happen the bigger my audience
gets the more i get to do that [ __ ] and
i can't do it without you so thank you
spider koi far from fandom
no more koi love in the chat though no
more coilovers
i'm really happy for you you are the
biggest comic fan i've ever known in my
entire life and if there's anyone who
deserves that level of success it's you
and when i say and rehearse all leak and
go suck it [ __ ] dick all right we'd have
a non-notable voice marshall yeah
dude and i when i saw your instagram
post i was like oh dude what koi's
introducing this is like the elk dude it
came out of no and i was like yeah i'll
be there i was so happy for you in that
moment
no one i know deserves that more it was
so surreal to look out at 1300 people
and just be like i'm gonna talk about
eternals to you like it was it was one
of those life moments i got to do the 22
on the road to end game as well i got to
introduce four marvel films in the
run-up to end game and then talk to the
russos and kevin about it and then to do
this was uh i i'm gonna die and these
moments will flash back my life these
are gonna be those moments of of like i
did something worthwhile in between all
of the yelling at bigots the man niraj
krishnan thank you for the little fans
sticker and got a little fan base
roger the man
jackie chan
uh name no name nope frank dx hey guys
definitely agree with you guys opinions
on the movie all of us that's
interesting i'll go watch it tonight
again celestial cgi we're mind-blowing
pretty excited to see in the future
galactus and allen's glory well thank
you for the super chat i'm glad you
enjoyed it absolutely
jim x mafia hey john and greck um
do you think celestial is huge sure
that's the twist actually is they're
really tiny and
have you seen that episode where
spongebob and patrick find the the the
belt uh with the miniaturization they
flip it to w for wumbo and they shrink
all of bikini bottom and then plankton
shows back up at the end he's huge by
comparison he's like what happened here
that's the mcu awesome yeah absolutely
mustafa yav
or jav do you think extra exposition
could have been helpful followed by
holding off on origins for a little bit
i think what would have been helpful is
to turn this into a tv show
solve both problems at the start yeah
exactly yes uh morgana
for every time koi roasted idiots during
this livestream seriously cooling on the
koi i didn't even see the live chat i
was just coming out i'm blind because i
know they're in there so i appreciate
you understanding that i was [ __ ]
decking fools assuming they're in there
corey was rehearsing in the car right
over here
also if you're in here later watch and
not live [ __ ] you yeah it's just
universal but i love most you just not
you but everyone else teague with the dc
references in the movie do you think the
director would have been doing a new
gods or fourth world movie
new gods would be [ __ ] poor amazing
yeah ava duvernay and tom king's new
gods is one of my biggest losses in
cinema second two uh we found out
recently that the it was gonna be new
gods and a trench movie over at dc and
they announced it as a trench but we
were all like wait i saw aquaman why the
[ __ ] would we have a 20 minute sequence
turned into a full film they didn't
reveal that it was actually a black
manta sequel they were trying to make
that i would have watched the [ __ ] out
of so because of the budget going to the
snyder cut and because of the dark side
taking the snyder cut we lost both new
gods which would have been a mr miracle
big bartender movie which would have
changed the entire pantheon of what dc
became and we would have had a black
panther movie which would have allowed
us to have a very different aquaman 2
which would have had a conflict between
two leads instead of one lead and a new
character we barely know and instead
dc is making these choices dude i think
this all sounds like [ __ ] boy
i think it all sounds terrible
that's what dc stands for is dumb
choices all right i like a lot of their
the dumer crazy thought what if all the
god pantheons in the mcu odin zeus thor
et cetera are just robots
that would suck i would hate that
like
i would like to absolutely hate that
what
don't do this to us the doomer that
would be the movie don't don't you know
he
everything was a dream moment like i
don't want everything to be a treat i
hope in the last mcu movie they just
zoom out to reveal this was all taking
place in a comic book
that some kid is reading yeah
that an ancient koi chandra is reading
it's me and brody from mall rats like
flippin comics aline goslin you're not
the only one cursed with knowledge i
wonder if thanos knew the celestial's
plan given watching new rockstars post
and
down
i mean maybe i like that a lot i i'm
cool with celestials and thanos having
some some bro i think it would just
enhance the world and then i love the
idea of really connecting it in
especially if celestia was going to be
probably the next big thing yeah i like
conquer or something i don't know which
one
he also knew king the conqueror
belladonna 1363. coy thank you for
always speaking out for people of color
lgbtq
people it means a lot i feel greg might
give people too much
that's the first time i've ever seen
greg be the altruistic one on the
internet ever that's amazing look at you
greg being too nice
greg is always awesome i feel like it's
a criticism about me no you're saying
too much
you assume better at people or am i just
so optimistic i see that as a yeah i'm
like i feel like you have too much
people
you're assuming they're better than they
are i'm the only person of color here in
this live stream and the only one part
of the lg but you said i feel greg might
give people too much of their dad and
then you're like you think they're
better than they are so you're you're
more optimistic than me yeah yeah it's
uh that's why is that how it reads john
howard how do you read that um
i get where greg is coming from
even john's in the middle honestly i get
where you're
i mean because you know you you have
this uh there's a bit of a uh i don't
know what to call it there's like a
motif now where it's like you've come on
these live streams a couple of times you
know you've launched out into some very
epic rants
you know uh marginalized people and so
you know i mean given the conversation
we had earlier about having like okay i
want to understand what my friend who
didn't have you know a good feeling
about the kiss scene or whatever you
know like but you know you know i think
it is is because i am a mostly straight
white dude so i'm in a position of
privilege where i can yell at other
white straight dudes and go like [ __ ]
you specifically where like greg being a
person of color they can attack him in a
way they can attack me like what are
they gonna call me like i'm privileged
enough to say like [ __ ] you guys for not
understanding this oh he's my white save
no but without being notable without
being a white savior i've never i've
never said but i've never said like oh
look at me you're both doing the lord's
work
and i've never been about me or i try
not to and that greg wants to understand
like people who don't seem malicious but
who have the opposing or the problematic
point of view you want to understand
maybe where that comes from and see if
you can reach maybe some kind of i don't
know progress despite that there's a lot
you can a lot of people you can't do
that would and right there i think more
nazis need to get punished and there's a
few you can do that a lot of people have
an actual discussion with him yeah i
think a lot of the time you would
probably fall into you know koi's uh
mode for this and then given the
opportunity with somebody who is
receptive the colby covington fight with
ousman last night and that dude's a maga
[ __ ] and him getting his ass kicked
by nigerian made me so happy like punch
more nazis i need to see that happen
christian alontay i really liked it but
i was also one of the only people in
school that liked reading the iliad and
this reminded me of that in a way that's
a good touchstone absolutely it's
definitely got like an epic scope of
like an old play yeah
i i can i can appreciate that
sure i can appreciate the intentions
always that's a good compromise
competition approach
or pono any thoughts on what tyrone said
shaking my head what did he say who's
tyrone tyrone magnus what did he say
like about eternals did he save the
movie sex
who's tyrone magnus the great child
magnus
is he is he and marvel i don't know
i know a lot of marvel kings he's a
celestial i like i'm very tyrone magnus
is one of the bigger celestials
to clip this guy like what's a tyrone
magnus
is it like a politician
there's a reaction channel oh he's like
another oh okay god she's got almost 2
million followers what did he say
someone tell me about someone tell us
what he's tyrone matthews i'll learn
later i'll watch him your mom coy your
mom is in the chat talk and i have 32
long boxes
32 long boxes of koi's collection at my
house on the east coast and they're full
300 each that's what like nine thousand
six hundred bucks yeah there's like over
nine thousand it's over nine thousand
tyrone magnus leave it in the chat and
maybe we'll see what tyrone says so now
lily aguilera sounds like it could be a
dc character hello guys do you think he
does know zack snyder
hello guys do you think the eternals is
the marvel version of bvs is that
divisive love your content guys i
absolutely don't think that no no
because i don't think it completely goes
i don't know yeah i don't i wouldn't
call it that but i would liken this
experience more to that in in terms of
like
panned but a lot of people were like i
was also rally behind not this movie's
not rallying behind chloe zhao they're
rallying behind a marvel movie yeah
because marvel didn't want to step in
and cut this down to somewhere
dc had a very rally around zack snyder
and i do feel like this is more dna with
snyder cut because the snyder cut
allowed us to feel like gods walked
amongst us and that to me feels more
like the snyder dna people keep talking
about like it's more justice league than
it is bvs and i love the the batman
scene in bvs but overall the movie
didn't get the time to breathe that
eternals did so i don't think it's fair
to compare the two i do feel like zack
snyder is a genius filmmaker that has
been shackled at times whereas this
wasn't uh chloe being shackled so i
don't think it's necessarily fair to
look at anything up until the snyder cut
to compare the two
[Music]
fair enough thank you lily i think we
may have reached the end of our super
chats
are pretty good yeah by then we'll know
what's refresh the stream labs really
quick thank you all thank you so much we
got you guys been very kind
especially we're checking and sticking
around with us we spend way too much
time usually per answer
we love answering poll agrees that
coulson is not a celestial
but great great troll 32
uh this was the closest poll and 32
percent voted super yes super yes so i
think you know there could be some uh
wiggle room there we need to give
everyone a break before john campio goes
live yeah yeah yeah
do you know i talked to him for the
first time about this movie me and candy
had a great conversation i he really
loved it like i did and i i like his his
view on it i'm glad you guys came oh you
guys bond we did we talked outside the
screen and had a little had a little bro
about it it was good it was real good i
respect his take on this
witcher and we gotta edit some more [ __ ]
and i gotta help out koi with something
too so first we gotta go we got to we
definitely gotta call it man all right
let's get this john load the internet
faster
faster you know how to go up there oh
that's right we still gotta shoot
witcher today don't we oh yeah good here
we
go
all right craig brennan thank you so
much for the little uh for the little
pear sticker doing the little jumpy
dance there
really enjoy the sticks as well
let's do the last of the stream labs
um
people really want to fight me on this
hey yo do we get josh martin i think we
got a josh martin i don't know if that's
the same josh martin
no yeah we did that we got credence we
got i think we didn't get josh martin
okay
criticism
no no we didn't get that that's the one
okay all right we'll do this really
quick uh josh martin hey y'all love each
and every one of you guys and the work
you do for me i really enjoyed eternals
and perplexed by the criticism is this
because it's not a traditional mcu movie
and more of a chloe zhao movie
uh that was the one you got snarky and
said yes i agree with that that was
during the super chat maybe you went
over both but yes it's because it's not
a traditional mcu movie i'll say
this is my favorite of chloe joe's work
which is not the common uh i like this
more than no mad land which got best
picture a lot of people hate that movie
in fact most of the conversation i hear
about is people going i hated no man
land it feels like poverty points
well no it just feels like it's like
it's making a commentary on people that
don't understand the people kind of like
big bang theory like i feel like big
bang theory is punching down at nerds
and i feel like no man lands punching
down on people that actually live in a
trailer so if you've ever been a part of
that culture been to burning man or been
to the desert culture it's not it's not
authentic to that and that to me like
took me out of the film you always give
quality answers i just like it i gotta
make sure super chat
mez guys ajax made her mind up because
of the fight against thanos and the snap
back it was the final uh feat that
convinced her of humanity's capacity for
love and self-sacrifice she had already
started to doubt aeroshem's design this
was what sealed it yeah she started
doubting seven thousand years ago no i
think the thanos thing like i was saying
but that's well known
yes it's very well put and i still think
she had plenty of time even after the
snap she had more than six days good
snap just happened like a month ago
what what is this do we know the
timeline we don't i mean i couldn't i've
only seen it once
it's impossible that snap just happened
like just that recently right
i mean the snap just happened
theoretically shanxi this and
the shows could all happen
simultaneously because no one entered
like no one's in each of them i guess
the question comes down to did the snap
happen two weeks ago because then it
would work did it happen yes then then
i'd be like this just happened that
could work
i felt like it was just another re i
thought it was just
one of her reasons when the movie
shows you
yes she uses that as one of her reasons
right but seven thousand years ago when
talking to charge if she was she was
saying
i don't think we should she was already
trying to bring up her doubt so i
believe she's been doubting and wanting
to not do this for seven thousand years
back it was like yo i like these people
i like them a lot yeah for 7 000 years
she's already i feel like she made this
decision way before the snap
i see we're coming from i think the snap
was just another one of the reasons
a noop
i thought the movie was way better
than the reviews didn't understand how
they were worse than wonder woman 84. oh
wow i didn't realize that also didn't
get how eternals was an intellectual
piece as few pointed out was the
standard save the world from destruction
lol i love this this is perfect it's
it's like i don't get why i got so much
hate it was good also it ain't as deep
as people are saying it
yeah this is a great way i don't even
really acknowledge how okay this is here
we are it's not as bad as this it's not
as deep as this there we go this is fine
guys super okay art is interpretive i
love this take that might be my favorite
comment
favorite one all the day well done
all right mezz is back yes yes we just
re-read it we're ready to go i'm with
koi on this just please apologize for
double messaging first time supporter
long time listening love the energy and
all the best with child well i
appreciate it and i agree to disagree on
that thing i think that was just one of
the reasons another reason to add on to
when i think the real reason why ajax
went against this is all the other [ __ ]
she talked about with like i've seen all
the terrible things they've done i've
seen all the great things they they've
done too and the snap is just one of the
great things yes but i think it's all
the collective experiences over the last
7 000 years are really the thing that
made her happy but if they're eternal
seven thousand years could be like a
week for us if she lives for a hundred
thousand years must move but definitely
any time maybe so maybe she could doubt
something as the years be like i think
you [ __ ] feel seven thousand years
ago
what's
what's important is that flev doran
says that you did succeed coy the point
of artists is to create and tell stories
and entertain people and if you can
enter a room and instantly grab people's
attention like you did here on real
rejects you succeeded
flev you get it you get it we're on the
same page i used to see koi a lot in the
same room but would never talk to him
i didn't know that for years but as i
wrote our first phone call was a big
epiphany what a lot of people don't know
is i hadn't seen coy a lot online and i
was a little nervous to approach him and
i never talked to him just because i was
like this guy is so much bigger than me
in my own head is how i view him
so i i like that
and then when you recruited me for the
showdown team i'm like you remember me
yeah i was like i've got this giant
channel that i respect with john who i
know from coffee
right now
i literally was like i was like john
from coffee and greg who i really
respected admire and john who i
respected my
you guys are one of the only five
channels i was subscribed to
literally you found out when like you
opened my page you were like you don't
follow collateral i was like
like i literally you guys were one of
five so yeah so yeah not at all which is
very it's very flattering but yeah i
appreciate that very much but i love
that you're both like
i was like i know john's life
we've known koi for a while yeah five
subscribers you guys are one of my five
i follow oh never follow anyone so
tyrone got backlash for not liking the
gay kiss and looper i understand if
you'd rather not address it right now i
mean okay if that's how tyrone feels
well no person tyrod i will say that i
feel like we talked pretty extensively
about this subject at the top of this at
the earlier part of the stream
was it like he had a problem with them
being gay or did he think that just
having a relationship with the movie was
a pacing issue was it i mean i guess we
closed the chat so it doesn't matter but
like i don't know so liking it more to
like the conversation i was saying i had
earlier is more how i would imagine
tyrone feels yeah but i can't assume
maybe you should do a live stream and
really break it down it'll just make
asses out of all of us
who's tyrone matthews
back in the action about the d plus
shows maybe not connecting with the
films i get ptsd from all the years
re-watching all mcu tv
uh
shows thinking it would matter yes
including inhumans anyway can't wait for
no way home and the sixth spoiler live
stream after it
take care that's gonna be a killer live
stream we're gonna have so much fun
that's gonna be an off-road live stream
if ever there was one thank you for the
for the the contribution here ship more
than anything else i love that the movie
is trying to cater to and represent the
world with different cultures races
languages etc amazing that so many
underrepresented groups get to see
themselves on screen kicking ass by the
way i love your channel it's all john
man it's all john love you john you've
really held down the fort here for so
long three hours oh john and uh yeah i
think that's great diversity is awesome
but i also hate that it shoved in my
face yeah down my throat
damn it freaking gender bending things
for comics i didn't actually read i am
so much that yeah i read this character
wikipedia and i read he was male and now
he's not comics explained
opinion from 10 minutes ago it's funny
to me because this is one of the casts
where i'm like this really does feel
like a very diverse cast without it
being like this is the point at no point
when i watched this was i like huh
they've got a person from different
things i was like look at all these
great actors and i think it never was
pulled out of it i think it's arguably i
mean putting the kiss directly front and
center does
kind of go guys look but i didn't feel
like a couple already yeah but of all
the disney attempts lately to be
inclusive this movie felt a little more
genuine about it star wars literally hit
it then trying to hit inclusivity points
putting like a gay couple in the
background to kiss and be like hey we
got a few points they set up pen and
[ __ ] poe as [ __ ] and then they
were like by the way he's got a
girlfriend and then they had a couple
kissing in the background like it's just
i don't know if if uh if if brian tyree
henry kissed a woman in that if that was
the exact the whole point of that no one
would have a conversation no one have a
conversation and the whole point but the
thing is i'm not gonna sit here and say
that it's not like the people who made
this were unaware that this would draw
attention for being a gay kiss scene you
know but they weren't advertising what
they were that yeah i didn't think so
either and i think some people will take
it like that only because they were
already going to take it like that no
matter what they did
they're
that it's gonna happen yeah they've
written their [ __ ] bill like picket
signs and nothing will change that there
are other people already that's
predetermined to respond that kiss was
so sentimental and loving it wasn't like
oh baby oh baby like i just that's
seeing other kinds of people represented
and thriving on screen truly makes me
happy when it's done properly yeah it
should never be something that angers
you because you can just turn on
avengers philly geez i'm just a girl uh
sorry philly g
thank you for the moment of silence my
friend really appreciate that did katy
perry get kicked back for i kissed a
girl and i liked it like that's the same
that's uh you know that was way more
difficult
white men love when two women hook up
yeah
it's very different
versus like this being a background
choice i only like lesbians who are also
only attracted to me
[Laughter]
it's so great to finally see a south
asian superhero in the mcu who's funny
and hot love kingo great representation
of the culture with the wedding and
funeral scenes but the bollywood dance
sequence felt more like a parody
in my opinion yeah it was not a good
bollywood dance yeah i was like you
didn't throw down maybe as hard as you
could have on
yeah i was like this guy's the superstar
like apparently he didn't know he was
like signed on yeah i'm like i saw the
interview so was it distracting cause i
don't know bollywood that well i mean
i've seen a cut a few bollywood dance
numbers but the fact that of how it it's
just you could just tell it's really
under under a choreograph for him and he
didn't really give him time to properly
train for it and stuff yeah he got finn
jones all right but it is stoic and
doesn't really move much like another
character who he's playing in that movie
yep hey what could arguably arguably an
intentional icarus his other his other
films are way more animated
darth harkness mick murray coy read our
last one of the day coy talking about
mcu irish heroes don't forget the
parents of steve rogers are poor irish
immigrants so he's irish too netflix mcu
daredevil is irish too now to bring in
black tom from deadpool 2. banshee from
first class maybe shamrock too fun fact
i ran into conor mcgregor once at a
restaurant and pitched him playing black
i'm not even kidding playing black tom
and he said and i quote oh i'd kick all
the [ __ ] x-men and it to this day is
one of my favorite moments in my adult
life him telling me he would take out
all of the x-men
um but yes steve rogers is a noted first
generation irish american and it is near
and dear to my heart that chris evans is
from the first city of america boston
massachusetts where ya boy is from as
well as a uh as an irishman it does make
me happy to hear the irish lilt and i
hope we get more of that in this world
but it was much more important to me to
see all these characters that people are
angry about because uh it really reveals
people's true colors in a very
interesting way um not a lot of people
get mad at irish people but except
around the holidays
and when the red sox win doing one more
refresher just to make sure we got
everybody but thank you all i think we
did uh the last poll of the day we need
to regain some energy before we shoot
witcher which is a very heady focused
show with a lot of different okay we got
one more here
it's about you koi take it kung fu hot
dog love you guys koi is still a gym
shark and did you get back you're fixed
what is fixed uh you mentioned looking
crow magnet oh like getting fixed back
at the gym uh i actually just rejoined
the gym the gym
so the gym there we go there it is there
it is i got nothing on you remember you
said i was small last time and i took
that personally
you've noticed you're just so much
bigger i am
more so much bigger decoy remember when
you said i was small and i took it
personally josh you know you gotta
[ __ ] you got some gains now you're
just way bigger some [ __ ] work
boy so so last time i was here greg
actually pointed out i've gotten smaller
and it actually affected my gains i went
immediately to the gym that day
your arms look like naturally big you
don't even have to flex my arms look
small and then they get big if i flex
but i'm so pale you can't see the
definition i'm like i glow in the dark
uh both of your biceps are bigger than
my head it's the end of the stream
they're both bigger than my head
it's literally the end of the stream
when you ask the gym question and we
technically have a mirror on camera
right now i was here i walked in and
greg was like hey man you look smaller
what happened i kid you not now and you
know if you're a gym bro you're like
well that means one thing and i left
here you lost a bunch of weight i dip
but it affected all of them i didn't
think you like lost some muscle when do
you oh when you hear that it feels like
you know what that feels like you know i
get i never get told i lost but i always
get told did you gain weight
that's what i'm always doing this morphe
affects all sizes and spectrums uh so my
gym wasn't uh it had no mass mandix it's
out of la county so i'd go to the gym
and be like i'ma die here so i like
didn't go so the gym close to me is
literally three times the price and i
didn't go for two months and then i was
like wait there's a new year's deal so i
joined pay extra and get and get the
wrong and get the wrong but i rejoined
uh six days ago and i've gone every day
for six days and i'm starting to see
them gains so it's working because of
your your challenge [ __ ] yeah i i credit
you
because i took it personally you're
responsible
yeah if you ever want to bulk up for
something just challenge my game really
diminish his self-esteem oh he's just
taking some inspiration for the machine
to start a week away
looking bale nine man
maybe some rescue dawn [ __ ] are
you about to play some prisoner of war
in a movie i'm just curious is there a
role in your future as a small child
because uh it seems like that's the
direction you're going are you doing
pre-serum i'm playing sprite in fact in
the next we gotta end this all right we
got so much more to handle and uh you
guys have been great coy has
you guys have easily been the stars of
this stream and i appreciate you both
very much for being here on the show oh
[ __ ] we got thank you also uh to the to
the folks
sean mclaughlin and wayne ventar for
sending in some stickers at the very
very end thank you so much appreciate
those stickers lovely love uh you guys
have been incredible to us and i really
appreciate uh everyone who's been here
this entire time and uh from uh we coy
and i were not really aware of the
actual chat this time around
what
john for making the chats fun though and
for voting in the polls the final poll
of 48 of you say they're absolutely
going to see this again in theaters it
didn't seem exactly too
toxic to chat did you get ever out of
hand i had a
boot a few people but you know that's
par for the course but overall it was
our overall very supportive very
respectful awesome very enthusiastic
awesome okay
well thank you guys so much coy you're
the man this is really your stream john
you're second i'm third
but we all know that really it's tyrone
magnus who stole the show
i gotta google this dude is he like a
thing
uh yeah i guess so good for him uh and
uh sean mclaughlin your big dick uh all
right guys we're going to do this we'll
see you guys soon thank you so much for
being here we'll have you watch you guys
soon
thank you for that the ending
thank you everyone was here hopefully
you enjoyed the stream
much love and we are ending this tonight
right right now tonight
after spider-man no way home i'll give
you guys some flashlights ending the
stream
until you flex coy
we can't even end the stream your stream
will stop immediately once koi flexes
that was long that was long we did it
we did it you guys
2 30.
three hours turn off the
that was actually way more peaceful than
i expected like i feel like matrix was
way more aggressive but then again we
didn't look at it at all is there a
spider-man poster